so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody I am Thomas
doubles y'all whatever you want to call
me you don't know but that was a 99
minute intro we just did played the
intro back 71 times because we all kept
talking over each other here we go this
is my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up
folks we're in that bright blue bills
looks hard guys you guys ask every other
day for this person to come back on the
show but he's afraid of the camera and
he's my son so I don't let him out of
the house too often hi OG thank you for
coming back thanks for coming back
oh now you got low he was just screaming
yeah he was just scream talking he's
getting real controversial it was
moments ago pretend the cameras aren't
on
are you sure all right uh that might I
think you're good I think you're good
this is your third time or fourth time
back
but I want to say third time here's a
random Chapel he'd be walking in with it
I feel like that's true shaking in his
boots
you'll be all right it's okay oh geez
doesn't look nervous today you barely
drank anyone your lips are barely red
this will drink wine cracked a beer
dropped a beer and drink a shot the
whole podcast yeah yeah we've been here
for an hour just started it's been an
hour already yeah it's okay here we go
what's up fool
where's my phone there you go how you
doing you're right what's up all right
I'm good you sure you ready I'm gonna
get straight I'm gonna start all right
let's get right to these fan questions
right away all right we have some fan
questions for you and that means some
fans ask some questions fans all right I
knew you didn't know what I was talking
about yeah
just right before we got in here what we
were talking about that's what I thought
you said
offensive things that he knew we not
allowed to say we just didn't want to
get the channel just literally just
deleted off of YouTube as a whole here
we go with the most politically correct
person I've ever met right here we go
fresh off Instagram here we go you ready
for I'll do the first by the way what
what what by the way because we had a
really highly requested guest off
Instagram again that the fans just help
us get booked coming in real hot oh yeah
a little bit
we got Julia coming in yeah we have uh
some some rapper coming in some artist
that's he's just gonna fight he's gonna
fight you OG he's really buff and he's
scary looking oh [ __ ] let's do it he
actually asked like you think oh do you
want to fight him
who's that I'm kidding yo bring you that
we asked fan questions whoever this guy
is somebody put in the fan questions and
I just responded back to him let me say
this Thomas is always hyping this fool
up that follows he's a dick I worked at
Sand something casino that guy's an
[ __ ] I think it's the guy who threw
the [ __ ] money at in the face the
casino story Oh you mean the guy that is
he is he Max the kid with a beard
probably almost 40. that's what the guy
looked like oh really he commented right
now I just responded right before he
pulled up oh he's like guys you're
always hype anymore this guy's a [ __ ]
dick he's an [ __ ] I've met him before
not cool at all I work at something
something Casino sand something Casino
Oh you mean that's it with an m with an
N is that the guy you think it's the guy
that probably probably is yeah I even
wrote back if you had a bad experience
you're the problem and you're lame
because this was chill what are you
talking about I think that was a guy who
asked me to put my mask back on him and
I'm running like literally in the
[ __ ] parking lot outside he's like
put your mask I'm like [ __ ] out of here
and then he said that you win he said I
um I think I said uh I didn't answer
because yeah you lost and like oh my God
bam I threw my [ __ ] a tip he [ __ ]
go food it's probably him then you know
what I mean that's probably I was
probably walking around doing nobody
tell us today but I mean [ __ ] you went
gambling today no no no I'm saying that
thing I lost that day but [ __ ] doesn't
mean I'm a loser
yeah but I'm saying there's probably
more than one person who might have said
some [ __ ] you [ __ ] said some [ __ ] to
him remember what casino sand and then
started with an M yeah oh that's the guy
that has to be that guy's a dick hella
rude
foreign
I mean if you come at me and you tell me
something stupid at a moment of time you
know I'm gonna answer you stupid too
yeah you're kind of saying something
about yourself I'm cool as [ __ ] you know
I mean I get a lot of little fans hit me
up here and there and you know I guess
they recognize you know I mean from
Thomas and Shawn Shane and they come up
to me oh yo yeah fool what's up man I
mean I'm cool you know even literally in
the car side to side cars that pulled up
to me and they're like what's up oh [ __ ]
what's up man you do kind of intimidate
I've had fans be like I've seen all GI
dtpg I was too afraid to say something
yeah you know I do get that I do see
some people and they just tell me oh you
know why imagine me coming up to you
like this
I see my eyes I ain't smiling you're
scary you have glasses on 24 7. I don't
I can't read you fool you just look like
the little homies in the machine
lowrider yeah the little toys
they don't find that you know they think
oh but this is probably matters at the
end and you're at work yeah no I'm cool
man she coming to me anytime and say
what's up that's what I'm saying people
don't I get it like I said the first
time I ever made people always say how'd
you meet him like At first I'm like
some training day [ __ ] and it was your
it was Snuffy I'm like
this one was crazy it's not with the
beanie like this and I walked into his
garage he like I let us in like oh [ __ ]
and then now I know they're your dogs I
just saw dogs at the thing and I saw the
dog next door I'm like
[ __ ] that guy but the guy introduced us
yo that's that's funny that's how we got
that's how we met but you said he was
going to push trees [ __ ] though right no
I saw him on the internet he was walking
push trees but when I went to his house
I'm like but I've been here before it's
called 12th Street this doesn't end well
in Merced why am I going in here with it
a long time ago why am I going in here
with packs that's all I thought of like
yeah we're good we're good my phone was
like my friend won't buy some weed I'm
like I got some trash is he wanted
remember it was the the year of the out
and I thought it took it a year of the
doctor and what I do when he took it I'm
like he was just trying to be nice I
think because that [ __ ] was trash
and he was over here in the microscope
I'm looking at it like
a diamond thing I was looking for some
piano
and then he smoked out of a weed pipe
and I was like yo what garage am I in
this garage I don't know if I could get
out of this [ __ ] place there's no
handle on the outside I'm like
yeah but who I was with I'm like no I'm
cool I'm cool and online I followed him
right he seems chill but that doesn't
never always mean like you're fine he
seems chill some people die that way
so when I walked in I was like oh I put
the Cranberries were playing
that in your hair I was like wait
yeah
that's way scarier no I was like yo is
this
wait who'd you bring me to because all
of her was the Grand I was like what the
[ __ ]
yeah they threw me off right yeah and
then we'd be chilling that's it that's
how we met yeah
but did you guys start being friends
right away or it took some time no right
away right away we chill we're cool
we're next right at first he seemed a
little like what no because you know why
I won't get into it that first thing
that happened that night yeah said some
wild [ __ ] to me and I was like what the
[ __ ] how about you at bulls and he's
like what no but he called them Spirits
he caught it he called them Spirits not
UFOs and I was like
you do what with Spirits for
I grabbed my packs and I was on the way
I grabbed the door and they're like what
are you doing I'm like I'm [ __ ]
leaving what if he was just really
religious like did it well the way he
said I'm like did you just say you're
bro I'm [ __ ] out of here because he
said spirit and he's like no I I said
you a frozen show or like I'll see you
know we all see like oars like what is
that but he said it like oh I see
spirits and [ __ ] I'm like I'm [ __ ]
out right away or out 30 minutes saying
we're smoking this boy has no shirt on
completely [ __ ] Danny Trejo tatted I
don't know about this bro we're Spirits
are [ __ ] out of here the next time I
came we chilled
you got up and was like I started
putting my pounds in my bag and I went
to his death
I was like no I'm a leaf before you even
checked out the weed that he came so he
kind of I was already checking it out
and then he was kind of putting it back
and I'm like oh let me see what you got
you know what I mean and then I checked
out what he has I'm like well I'll take
this yeah did you realize you were
freaking him out or are you just no I
didn't but you know what people do
always get freaked out at the beginning
they're like what the [ __ ] you saying
I'm like so I just see [ __ ] full like
what the [ __ ] I guess he wasn't ready
for it you know just like no no not even
therefore if you would have said yo
sometimes I see UFOs out here bro
easterly is crazy I'm like yeah me too I
see or [ __ ] fly I'll be on the freeway
I've done this UFO stories so I'm like
that's not weird to me but when he says
I [ __ ] with spirits and [ __ ] I'm like oh
I'm gone I'm [ __ ] out I don't [ __ ]
with spirits but the way he said it I
mean you could have said yo you believe
in your foes I see [ __ ] all the time man
I took a picture of one
said that
pick me the [ __ ] out bro
you literally got up
and my homie that Broad and said what
are you doing like I'm leaving so you
should say you [ __ ] with Spears I'm out
that's all I said I was like I'm out I'm
always blowing as hell I was like no I'm
[ __ ] leaping do you say [ __ ] like
that to new people often no no no I
didn't tell him I see Spirit he just I
kind of like it was just the way I put
it he put it this way what the [ __ ] so
you know no usually I mean I don't even
have to tell nobody but you know I mean
I think that day I think there was some
[ __ ] going it was our homie that was
there because he looked at your table
I'll tell you exactly what happened he
looked at your table where your weed was
and he goes
so you believe in something something
something and you had your like your
copper Tesla coil triangle with the
rocks in it oh yeah and he knew what it
was and you go you know about something
something like what the [ __ ] you guys
talking about and it's just like some
Nikolai Tesla [ __ ] coil thing it just
sparked the conversation and he goes
yeah boys be seeing spirits and [ __ ] my
friend's like oh no way and I went um
out like you guys can hang out I'm
leaving yeah this is before I ever even
lived in L.A this is so [ __ ] long ago
it was so fun because I don't know I've
known people that like when like they'll
have they'll like believe like my mom
was like that but she would talk to you
as if you believed exactly like she did
right off the bat you know and that can
definitely make people feel like
uncomfortable thank you
yeah you can definitely but the way you
say your mom was like clicking rocks
together and [ __ ] like one of those like
ladies like yo sit down I'm gonna I mean
read your mind or something to my pad
and we're not doing anywhere doing some
[ __ ] and he's like
well oh [ __ ] look there's some UFOs look
at this and he's like [ __ ] that I don't
want to see that he [ __ ] went in and
he's doing something else and then he
just looked out the door and he seated
and he saw what the [ __ ] is that
yeah you know what I mean that's what it
is there's some orbs and [ __ ] and he's
all like [ __ ] that he [ __ ] got his
[ __ ] and left and then he called me so
next time you do that she's call me let
me know I don't want to pull up when
you're doing it and it's not like let me
do that she's like yo we're just looking
up [ __ ] just look up yeah
exactly like you know gotcha seeing orbs
no acid or nothing else type of [ __ ]
going on I was there when I saw he's
like bro just look up because I always
say because they're already there we
already we're it's like they always just
show up all the time do you ever see I
know people in the comments I see white
lights and I see [ __ ] colorful lights
and lights dancing around she's like yo
me too what is it yeah that's what we're
talking about because he's like I called
him Spears because he doesn't know what
they are and he's like maybe they're
Angels maybe they're UFOs maybe they're
just entities maybe it's our eyes yeah
we don't know maybe it could be
ourselves coming back to see ourselves
because we're calling our own self so it
could be something that you know
Guardian Angel [ __ ] I'm sure you don't
understand yes yeah you know I mean I
can't say what it is because I mean
honestly I don't know but I mean I just
know that they do come out too much to
be light pollution or optical illusion
type [ __ ] oh yeah military they're good
[ __ ] I got hit with a [ __ ] Osprey one
time that was what's that mean one of
the one of the helicopters that like
goes up like uh
it was like day one of the pandemic and
I was like out in downtown L.A taking
photos oh yeah I saw some crazy videos
that got deleted off Twitter bro [ __ ]
helicopters going through the buildings
downtown like down the streets yeah this
should look like a drone I I turned and
like a drone off in the distance yeah
well you know what a lot of this [ __ ]
like you know come on listen this the
government has a lot of new [ __ ] you
know I mean they got [ __ ] their
events but they're not toying with these
things they're like 20 years Advanced so
what we get like now what we're seeing
right now they already thought about it
yeah there's only a certain time where
it got to come out and [ __ ] you know in
order for it to make a hit you know I
mean because if not
it's like now's not the time people are
not gonna understand it so we gotta wait
come on
you know electrical bikes already you
know and supposedly back [ __ ] you
know 100 years ago and [ __ ] but it just
wasn't the time you know and part dude
maybe they'll do that created that they
probably [ __ ] killed them because
maybe I mean time traveler and that's
how they knew it remember you're not
supposed to be doing that yeah we're
talking about some wild [ __ ] out here
today yeah yeah yeah but hey straight up
right I've been getting a lot of math I
mean I don't even want to get into it
because there was a water powered
vehicle situation I saw that too oh yeah
for sure situation a buffalo this [ __ ]
oh yeah crazy oh yeah I see this kid on
Tick Tock that I mean I mean it's
attraction dude yeah so it's [ __ ]
true bro I mean [ __ ]
I mean all these all these things that
are being created I mean [ __ ] I mean
it's someone that's already has seen it
so you know what I mean yeah just come
right back and if it's time to bring
that out it's time but if it's not bro I
believe that's when you're gonna get
smoked or something yeah it's not that
hard to go here's random act of violence
and that's why we don't talk about crazy
[ __ ] and when I say Spirits we're just
talking about hey sometimes if you look
up to be orbs that's all we're saying so
don't be thinking that we're all [ __ ]
smoke a lot of weed and [ __ ] over here
too yeah we're just talking about stuff
that other podcasts talk about
government leave us alone yeah Rogan's
still alive all he talks about is
exactly yeah exactly that was deeper and
[ __ ] yeah I mean I mean but yeah [ __ ]
um
look at Rogan likes your [ __ ] that was
really
ready to push tree [ __ ] that was random
that's one of my favorite posters of all
time that I just made one time the rock
climbers yeah it's rock climbers inside
this cat like catacombs that is nugs
nugs and it says keep on pushing the one
dudes like reaching down pulling the
other dude up that's pretty cool and I
said I just I don't know why I was just
like we're gonna like this show I just
sent it to him and he was like
yeah you loved it so we got a new push
trees fan in the building that's so
that's what you said yo we didn't even
get into question one yet
allow me
that's just hard look at this way
oh yeah I've seen that [ __ ] pretty cool
huh oh that's dope right yeah I just
[ __ ] I lost my man [ __ ] I had my
lighter too I gave well I got I'm not
really into desire to [ __ ] like that
please you know how I mean I'm not
really like yo I'm gonna get this and
you know that was a gift yeah yeah I
mean you're so into designer [ __ ] you're
making all your friends like knowing
about all of them got me some damn
guccis bro yeah I was like what the [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] you went to Burberry
for your birthday and you got Jason
Burberry [ __ ] well they all know about
that [ __ ] first yeah I know you're just
starting to know what is Jay at the top
of the food chain putting you on to the
[ __ ] though cause he seems like shows me
all stuff
that I haven't seen yet John Hash House
shows me designer stuffing cars
is Rosie up on does she know about all
this [ __ ] too the reason the only reason
I ever bought more shoes than just Vans
is because during quarantine me and
Rosie Watch Sex in the City
she's watching I watched I went dude
shoes are so important to a girl like
shoes are a [ __ ] they're like they're
the accessory so I'm like Rosie go buy
some [ __ ] shoes it's like dude
they're too expensive like how much well
oh [ __ ] that then we bought one and go
Rosie dude again [ __ ] it
you don't buy anything that's the only
reason I ever bought anything more than
just a push t-shirt in advance because
then I wouldn't look some stuff and go
wow that's pretty nice oh okay it just
makes you take care of [ __ ] like I'm
trying to get GTA storm like I got eight
[ __ ] shirts I got 10 pairs yeah so
I'm done yeah now you're somebody that
wears nice clothes that makes you feel
different like yeah he's trying to not
to Ash on myself you know like I try to
like keep it proper my car's spotless
all the time like I'm trying to like
keep it I don't know my car's a little
bit no no but besides the ashes I'm
saying like I don't keep cups in there
you'll never find a [ __ ] trash in
there more like a like my old car bike
bro there's there's [ __ ] weed sitting
there for [ __ ] two weeks ago you
talking about yeah like I'll throw
[ __ ] Ash on this I don't know I feel
like the universe likes that when you
just when you take care of it you just
take care of your [ __ ] I feel like that
that's good for your all-arounds it is
Big gratitude yeah it is it is but
anyway uh
I gave I got one of these before I gave
it to Rocco because my own like designer
stuff but now it's like you know what
it's orange it's sick and it was a gift
so I'm gonna keep this [ __ ] sick
um
yep what the [ __ ] are we talking about
oh yeah what's up fool won't you wear
your shoes
I wore them I wore them once and I was
like what kind of shoes are those
hold on what are they what are they
we'll pop them up on the screen right
there
you know which one what are they oh
they're what they're Gucci right yeah I
bought them I mean I don't know I mean I
don't even know I have no idea do they
got a picture of these things I mean
they look like shoes that OG would wear
I looked at and go oh would you wear
those shoes huh
is that my Levi's cover most of it so
you know I kind of don't you can't
really just look like what colors
they're green and red right they have a
green and red stripe what do you
probably you primarily wear like Nikes
and chair right yeah yeah they look just
like them I like them because of you
know my shoes my Levi's covered them you
know what I mean but I'm pretty sure
somebody else sees in they'll be like
what the [ __ ] is this guy [ __ ] wrong
with that you feel like
they're sneakers yeah yeah I mean I
don't care [ __ ] that's that's my thing
you know what I mean I'll make I'll make
this [ __ ] [ __ ] look like G [ __ ] I'll
make God turn everything yeah yeah yeah
I mean I can make a [ __ ] look different
yeah when I put it on you know what I
mean yeah we broke that down all last
episode about that's what makes a good
model yeah yeah with rock you're gonna
make my [ __ ] look cool just because you
know how to do it right yeah
um
so back to what we're saying we haven't
even got on one question yet are you
[ __ ] ready
first question this is from Instagram
this is from petard
I see his name I see his or her name pop
up all the time
what was OG's best experience on
mushrooms like
[ __ ] because you and Mindy been eating
the [ __ ] out of some mushrooms I mean
[ __ ]
dude I had a lot of experience with
mushrooms but I mean let's see if I want
to talk about my my good eyes I'm gonna
say back when uh [ __ ] high school man
[ __ ] yeah
there was one day when it was uh it was
like the fog came down it was Heavy you
couldn't even see down the streets I
mean it was [ __ ] here smog yeah
we heard about LA Smog when I was in
school no just fine you know the fog
came down it was real heavy and um [ __ ]
man I think I'm not sure if I think
we're together you know already I know
welcome we're going just to drive
throughs ordering food and just driving
right out not even [ __ ] getting the
food not even getting the food we passed
by we're like bye
you know there's no video games yet yeah
that [ __ ] was like at the moment you
know when you're shooting at you that's
just funny [ __ ] you you know you got
your shoes on shrooms and driving yeah
you know what I mean well let's go ahead
and you know go to a drive to order this
[ __ ] and it's just white with his temper
let's pull up we should not stealing it
just keep going you know what I mean and
you know we'll go to another drive
through and do the same [ __ ] over and
over just [ __ ] you know like you mean
to order each time
now we don't want this I don't think we
want this we're like bye [ __ ] this let's
go I'm mad at the size of my mushrooms
too like I want this no I don't get it
away from me yeah I do [ __ ] like that
all the time like with a joint I don't
even want this yeah it's weird I don't
know what it is I feel like it would be
weird to eat on mushrooms I've never
eaten on mushrooms hey I mean I think
yeah I mean wow I don't think I have
anything either I'm trying to like no
you never got the meal right yeah no no
I have it
but uh yeah yeah I mean [ __ ] I mean I
want to say when I was younger and then
once when I was about maybe about I want
to say
um
I want to say about maybe a year and a
half ago or two years maybe maybe we you
know me and uh one of my boys we took
about [ __ ] I think we took about what
six close to seven grams
um
and um my girl took him too and then
we're just [ __ ] bro hey FaceTime first
he starts off with hold my hand I'm
[ __ ] tripping the next thing you know
I'm like dude stop stop you know I'm
pretty good you know and this this was
like hold my hand I'm like [ __ ] I'm
gonna I'm gonna die I'm gonna go he's on
fading away and I'm like no you're not
and then like about maybe about 20
minutes later or half hour later after
his [ __ ] cuts off and he's doing good
now I'm gonna [ __ ] die I'm [ __ ]
you know what I mean like I'm [ __ ]
fading away and I'm like [ __ ]
what's happening I'm [ __ ] you know
what I mean and all I know is I sweated
like a a [ __ ] bucket of sweat bro my
[ __ ] that's what you did you're tripping
that's when you know you're gone
everything was [ __ ] drenched caveman
sweating and [ __ ] and uh [ __ ] I gotta
I found a towel and I was drying my face
and I go oh this feels good next thing
you know I got that towel and I wrapped
it around my neck and I'm like oh man
I'm never letting go of this towel his
towel makes me feel so good and I stood
on the couch for about
an hour or so [ __ ] that [ __ ] towel
just hugging my [ __ ] neck like [ __ ]
you know I'm not gonna let the pressure
going forward and holding I feel like I
felt I felt safe you know what I mean
and just at the moment like without that
moment all kinds of shit's happening
[ __ ] my brother's coming to the door
knocking hey what's up let me in and
we're like [ __ ] no get out of here don't
open the [ __ ] door get him out of
here this was gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up our
high right now he's selling some high
school she's like I'm [ __ ] my 40s bro
[ __ ] we didn't open the door for him
at all man we [ __ ] let them knock
could you imagine him having hearing
everyone having fun let me in yeah and
say no no you're not coming in and uh
[ __ ] after that maybe like about
maybe a couple maybe 45 minutes later
just [ __ ] started coming down so then
[ __ ] it we throw on [ __ ] the Allstate
commercials the old school jam I didn't
expect you to say that bro we're just
[ __ ] laughing our ass off bro all the
stupid [ __ ] he's doing you know [ __ ]
commercial that he's in the car [ __ ]
like you put them on too like let's
watch the All-Star yeah no no actually
my boy was like oh I want to watch
something funny let's put this on and we
put that on bro and it was just from
there on bro [ __ ]
[ __ ] laughing our asses off man so
crazy what about the mushroom trip
while I was coming over
and Carlo that we prank called on dang
calls had the ambulance come over and
the ambulance was there and he thought
he was dying yeah he did well actually
yeah some [ __ ] happened to him he got a
little weirded out wasn't that mushrooms
um right you guys are eating mushrooms
right
and that's when you freaked the [ __ ] out
yeah I guess yeah after while he freaked
out no no no he freaked no he was
already he was coming down off of him I
came over remember I came over and he
was remember that [ __ ] he was losing we
thought he was having an actual heart
attack yeah he was having some kind of
like anxiety [ __ ] you know what I
mean
you know we you know we [ __ ] around
always do some stupid [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
it let's take this oh [ __ ] it let's
let's grind them up today and let's
[ __ ] put orange and shut up let's
take him like this oh [ __ ] you know they
hit us [ __ ] faster and or you know
what I mean and yeah that day it really
got him he came over hit a blanket on
him yeah he had a heart attack and the
aimless kid yeah yeah they're like well
do you want us to take them but you
don't want us to take them I think he's
fine but and we're like do you want to
go and he's not like no I'm fine I'm
fine we're like [ __ ] [ __ ] 30
minutes ago you weren't fine you were
dying yeah now you know I'm fine I
walked in to smoke weed and they're just
[ __ ] Carl's just sitting there I'm
[ __ ] dying I remember before the
ambulance and coffee I'm all like no
he's all like [ __ ] I'm tripping I'm like
you wanna call the enemies like oh no
yeah and then after I'm like hold on I
got all my packs
it was still packs to the kitchen
remember I left you like it's a trash
bag right [ __ ] there bro there's so
many pounds
[ __ ] you know what I mean
you walking in
dude's [ __ ] freaking out in the
corner oh bro there's been times when
we're in my garage and and you know why
we will have somebody you know I had a
lot of [ __ ] people over there and
some of us like oh bro I'll [ __ ]
flipping out he's gonna pass out more
like hey guys get him pick him up take
him outside of my front porch get him
out of here you know because [ __ ] that I
don't [ __ ] want to come inside my
[ __ ] my microphone back then it was
like my shop you know what I mean so
like get him out of here you know me
[ __ ] it that's crazy how long has it
been to be chilling in that garage
four years
more than four years you know that
that's not yeah that's not true it's
true it's not true I've only been living
here for six and a half years it's been
okay I'm lying my bad you're right you
know it's been about three years two
three three years but actually since I
stopped everything and I cut the whole
thing is my first five years already
yeah it's been a long time since then
I'm just talking about hanging out in
the garage yeah like the garage used to
be the spot we always then again we both
none of us were productive
we just sat around like you can't just
hang out all day we just sat there and
[ __ ] torched and picked up and all
day figure out something to do taking
[ __ ] I mean another reason we [ __ ]
wasted bro so much we're pressing it
right there bro
[ __ ] a gram
instant another grand half gram
instantly we probably and it depressed
about 20 [ __ ] grams of hash in that
in those days out of day that's just
crazy like [ __ ] well smash like maybe
about [ __ ] two ounces at least and then
we're right there making big coins I'm
like oh yeah next thing you know the
next day I'm like [ __ ] what happened to
it remember with a big coin it's like a
little [ __ ] about rosin experiments for
like [ __ ] months dude like oh I think
I got it down you have to leave it in
this pocket and when you do it you whip
it remember all that [ __ ] and then
we would put different strings together
I don't man I don't miss it you know
mix and matching [ __ ] all the time I
hated wasting weed like that
yeah bro man that's crazy thinking about
how much we're just sitting there well I
remember when I was on I was on a dude I
was like on a little I was smoking hash
you know dry Sip and you know [ __ ]
the one you [ __ ] you know you heat up
the spoon and you know ice hat I don't
think Marty knows what that is spread it
out and [ __ ] you know ice and [ __ ] ice
hash not you know we smoke rosin what
they squish is Hash ice hash and what
you do is it's like little hedge you see
those trichome heads that people scoop
up in like macro videos it's not rosin
if you put it between paper
and you touch the top of it melts it no
uh bleep that complete that bleep that
we don't want to get in trouble okay you
you me you smooth it out like uh Fruit
Roll-Ups and you dab hash
it was more expensive because it was
like [ __ ] you know I mean the weed was
more expensive so far bro I think I was
buying grounds and [ __ ] for like
about
140 120 or yeah damn [ __ ] easy easy
400 bucks a day bro
how long were you just sitting there
squishing it like that for
oh [ __ ] when I got the presser forget it
bro forever every day everything every
day and what kind of rig do you have on
[Music]
[Laughter]
so I don't [ __ ] my [ __ ] up yeah well
I've watched Final Destination too many
times but like what if that falls and
bust my bong I clear off my counters
make sure there's nothing around it I
know [ __ ] that [ __ ] cleaning mine I'll
covert and [ __ ] with the [ __ ] house
Marty only smokes weed on the side of
his house in a hurry because all his
kids are so nosy still there's little
like yo what the [ __ ] what's going on
out there
what are you doing Dad I swear so every
time he FaceTime me and I see palm trees
above him I know he's the [ __ ] ladder
you put the phone right here and he's
like what's up I'm just smoking what's
going on and that's that somebody hits
me up and he smokes balls like this
have they ever ever walked in it was all
like no I just want to go out there I'm
[ __ ] fully situated and [ __ ] already
gotcha damn I did not miss those days my
little brother my cousin Memphis me and
Uncle John like oh is it good you good
all right ready
it's real all right cool we should do
that but hey you got some pizza you're
watching a SpongeBob movie again all
right
hit rails off the laundry room that was
outside and we could see him
all right go
remember I say Cocaine by candlelight
that was our [ __ ] because we want to
turn the lights on let everybody know
we're outside rails so I was here in the
darkness of the neighbors is
[Laughter]
yeah she was fun as [ __ ] yo so that was
a long rant
no okay hold on so going back to the fan
question here Thomas talks about at
those levels blasting off and
interacting with
entities have you are you doing that
type of [ __ ] or are you just yeah if
you're really high do you ever like
remember I told you when I was so [ __ ]
up with seven grams I was we did a whole
episode on him going up to us
oh no for sure when you're gone I mean
I want to say I do it I seem it's just
it's hard to explain bro I mean [ __ ]
because you've told me some [ __ ] before
yeah you mean just it's hard to explain
but yeah I mean [ __ ] it takes it to
another level where I mean uh
it opens up your mind with so much where
like it's just it's it's sad bro because
after you do that it's sad what you see
around you and you see how people are
living and you know like their mentality
is you know where the state of mind is
at all the time it's just like
like damn man it's
you know I can't help you yeah you know
I mean and and I'm at a point where like
you know I see what's going on but
I just can't do nothing about it do you
have this feeling I know we're not gonna
talk about too crazy
but you're saying like see what's going
on and what's going on like I I can't do
anything about it do you kind of feel
like you don't [ __ ] care anymore
um I mean I can find myself saying I
don't care but then I found myself like
[ __ ] stop more than ever so [ __ ]
much mad I think it's like a bipolar
feeling with me because I'm here you
know what I mean I'm here in it you know
what I mean and there's nothing I could
do about it I just I gotta go with that
we're talking about the life of the
video game called life that we're in the
game the [ __ ] not the simulation I'm
saying I'm saying like the game of the
game that we're in the level that we're
all on the plane
getting [ __ ] the RP yeah it's getting
[ __ ] worse and worse than the people
that control the level are [ __ ] it
so that's what we're saying so we're
more like yo don't drop the [ __ ] Call
of Duty bomb over here and I don't give
a [ __ ] bro I'm gonna keep doing my thing
and the NPC [ __ ] are gonna do
their thing and then you update and keep
doing the updates I don't care that's
how I feel lately like [ __ ] I don't
don't care anymore I used to give a [ __ ]
so much like nah man I could do
something else like
you guys win bro I don't take no pill
eat your steak [ __ ] I'm just
gonna sit
that's how I feel lately dude I don't
know what it is lately man the past
couple weeks oh yeah maybe two a month
but I mean I mean
I think it's it's always been around
it's just now it's just you know it's I
mean honestly it's also even social
media it's [ __ ] jealous you know yeah
and you know it's near generation you
know I mean they just I don't know bro
they watch too many movies and [ __ ] you
know what I mean and [ __ ] you know
listen too much rap and take it too
serious you know I mean when I mean [ __ ]
back then we used to listen and [ __ ] and
it was like all right yeah cool but
doesn't mean I'm gonna go [ __ ] go
through a drive-by right now because the
song said drive by yeah
atrocities are just normal now it wasn't
like things used to stand out back in
the day like horrible moments hit now
try like a tragedy gets drowned up by 62
[ __ ] tabloids off the Twitter feed
and you're like oh yeah
somebody did do that yesterday [ __ ] that
was yesterday I forgot
you should be like this on everybody's
brain for weeks and now it's just like a
little clip in Missouri in L.A you know
where everybody's just like what the
[ __ ]
everything's happening everywhere at all
times because everyone's got a phone it
was already happening I think before but
now that everyone's recording it
doing this while they do it showing
themselves it's like what the [ __ ]
uh it bugs me man yeah it bugs me it's
changed the game's changed the game is
washed up now you know what I mean it's
not the same no more
it's all right
should I live my life
I think I [ __ ] feel you oh God all
right
here we go
support for today's episode comes from
True classic all right guys if you're
shaped like me you already know finding
a shirt is super hard you're either skin
tied around your stomach or you look
like a box also for everyone out there
that has abs and six packs of course
this shirt's gonna look way way awesome
on you but for everyone out there that
doesn't have a six-pack this is a more
flattering shirt first thing you're
going to notice is the quality how soft
it is next thing you're going to notice
is how it fits your shoulders your dad
bod is evaporating Away by way this true
classic T true classic shirts taper
around the bottom and they're tighter
around the chest it's gonna highlight
your attributes all right you want your
shoulders to look better but you don't
want your gut poking out this is the
shirt for you they got this dope Builder
on their website you can package all the
different essential things that they
offer together also true classic does
not just stop a t-shirt they have polos
workout shirts boxers Breeze same exact
taper guys all right as the same fit for
all the wide dudes and the big tall guys
out there they all go up to xXx okay on
most of the staple colors free shipping
included on all orders over a hundred
dollars a hundred percent 30 day money
back guarantee and if you want to go
ahead and take advantage of this right
now go to trueclassic.com and use the
code checkout dope d-o-p-e that's going
to get you 25 off come on guys it
doesn't get better than that you guys
already know me I own a clothing company
so me looking at the shirts they are
good shirts at a reasonable price true
classic tees your dad Bible thank you
guys it's all about confidence when it
comes to sex right I'm right a bunch of
things can set you off down to a bad
path of not having fun stress anxiety
lack of sleep diet bluetooth.com to the
rescue Bluetooth online service has the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable form at a
fraction of the cost Bluetooth tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections in combat all forms of Ed and
because Bluetooth is an online
prescription service there's no awkward
conversations with a doctor there's no
weird office visits there's no bumping
into somebody you know at the pharmacy
getting your pills it goes direct to
your door and in the discreet box sign
up at blue.com they're going to link you
up with one of their medical providers
evaluate your situation within days you
should be receiving your prescription
best part it's all done online and
Bluetooth will work with you for your
dosage your prescription your strength
they are licensed medical providers
don't like swallowing pills no problem
Bluetooth tablets are chewable Bluetooth
is made here right in America guys and
there's no upsell to Pharmacy because
they're direct to Consumers special
offer for all the lessons owners you get
to try Bluetooth for free use code dope
at checkout pay five dollars for
shipping try it out for free use our
code dope at checkout and you get a
month your first month for free at
bluechew.com thank you guys so much for
being here back to the episode
second question at grostyle
[Laughter]
it's gonna be fun this is gonna be a
good question I mean this is has OG ever
experienced or encountered any
paranormal activities such as ghosts or
seeing shadows Etc
of course go to your grandpas talk about
your grandpa [ __ ] [ __ ] I've seen no I've
seen a lot of [ __ ] I've seen [ __ ] I mean
I think it all started I think when I
was about
five or four years old maybe I think
maybe no you know maybe five we talked
on one of your episodes about catching a
[ __ ] bad spirit and we try not to get
too into this [ __ ] but now that I think
that things are going on we can talk
about things more yeah I've seen uh when
I was five I've seen uh [ __ ] I don't
know what you want to call them but
whatever [ __ ] you want to calm the
devil's Lucifer whatever [ __ ] you
know but I've seen them you know what I
mean and he just gave me this big smile
and [ __ ]
in human form
Yeah well yeah it was it was [ __ ]
yeah it was
in my in my page you know I mean we had
a so we had back then you know we had
the freaking the the
what do you call the windows when
they're all [ __ ] with stained glasses
no no you know [ __ ] we used to put
the damn [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the bars and [ __ ] oh bars
[ __ ] I don't know I mean [ __ ] again
security Parts you know but they used to
you know all [ __ ] you know and [ __ ]
so I mean to me as I'm saying I don't
know how in the [ __ ] did he get through
those bars and [ __ ] got to open my
window and [ __ ] literally put his
whole [ __ ] face there you know what I
mean it's impossible where were you at
though I was in my room which house uh
my mom's house the one across the street
from you you know I just got out of the
shower I was [ __ ] going this [ __ ]
to my door to grab my little [ __ ]
butt Huggers and [ __ ] you know what I
mean
grabbing them you know [ __ ] you know I'm
still [ __ ] eating my towel around me
and I'm looking Something Told me look
at the wind I looked at the window and
so the curtains you know the window just
[ __ ] flapped out and I just seen this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] face with the
biggest [ __ ] smile
ever was it a human
uh well I guess a monster or a human no
no he didn't look human he looked
[ __ ] he looked like the [ __ ] devil
and a flash or like oh no he opened it
bad me looked at me he just smiling me
and I looked at it and I was like what
the [ __ ] and I was like whoa so I just
[ __ ] sat early I think everybody I
just got my [ __ ] my underwears I was
like [ __ ] this I [ __ ] ran out to the
[ __ ] into the kitchen and my mom was
right there she's like oh what was wrong
like [ __ ] you know I didn't even tell
her bro you know I just [ __ ] was like
I don't know I just whatever the [ __ ] I
don't know what I seen you know but I
didn't even tell her I haven't met I
told her now you know what I mean but
she ever see that [ __ ] in the house uh
no it's funny because um
now that I tell my mom my mom tells me
you know what it's funny you say that
because when she was a kid she goes I
seen them too uh what is it about
Mexican kids seeing some spiritual [ __ ]
cause my [ __ ] little step I mean they
might have already been something maybe
from our past you know our past our
ancestors or something they might be
already something there well that's
that's what I'm saying yeah you know
because so that's what I mean I've seen
it or something that's already something
that's just traveling from the past it
just you know it's just yeah oh you know
it's crazy people don't believe in this
[ __ ] and good don't believe in it
because probably never [ __ ] with you
hopefully no I mean I'm pretty sure yeah
there's a lot of people I mean a lot of
people might see [ __ ] and go nah I'm
tired and blow it off but the people
that really understand that there's
other things go
damn now I'm susceptible to this [ __ ] so
is there other stories in your family
about seeing similar crazy [ __ ] like
that no I mean well
you know my my son my you know my son
see [ __ ] what he's never told me this
[ __ ] yeah he used to [ __ ] come
running to us and [ __ ] and [ __ ] we've
been living room chilling it's the
little kid you know [ __ ] come running
till we're like what the [ __ ] what's
wrong with you and he just would never
tell us did you ask him later no until
finally he was still little and finally
like you know um I had one I had a
friend you know spiritual doctor I was
like I was talking and she told me it
was oh no she says because he's he sees
he's you know he's gifted he sees
something that you know I mean but
he's just not he's not telling you guys
but he sees some [ __ ] you know what I
mean like he's seen you know he could
see [ __ ] that you know that's from
another from another life you know what
I mean they're there around him probably
you know that's what they are that's why
he comes running through six cent style
oh crazy and I mean like you see some
[ __ ] and that's kind of like when I was
a kid that's the kind of [ __ ] that I
would be seeing too like little [ __ ]
like what like what the [ __ ] was that I
just seen something but all right [ __ ]
it I didn't see something I seen
something like it's [ __ ] with you is
how you're feeling 100 it's like even
till this day bro I mean I still I I see
[ __ ] I I could I could see a portal
bro just come out inside of me and I was
like what the [ __ ] and just explain that
because people think you're high uh just
like different [ __ ] like different stuff
you like lights will come next in
there's like [ __ ] looks like it's
[ __ ] like trying to open and I'm just
like if I'm looking straight I could
literally see it so it's got astigmatism
go to the doctors I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm kidding
but yeah
when I'm like you're not wrong because
you have because I've seen weird [ __ ]
too but I don't know what it is I feel
like lately it's more
well especially now I think I think
everybody is happening more now I mean
people
I mean just people don't want to accept
it if people see something yeah
[ __ ] something's wrong with me oh
[ __ ] I need glasses baby yeah because
I told you because now that I live there
at the da Vinci uh the apartment I lived
at
bruh I told you I think you know I saw
some [ __ ] there and I went damn bro here
too [ __ ] I used to see where she has a
kid too
I was walking down my hallway and I know
when something's next to me like [ __ ]
you I know he tries to stick up on me
you're [ __ ] a magician so I know when
someone's next to me
even in my own house where I'm going to
sleep in my own bathroom I look over my
shirt I [ __ ] hate that I'm so
paranoid I hate it I check every [ __ ]
closet everything every day I [ __ ]
hate it
anyway the da Vinci I was walking down
the hallway and you remember the da
Vinci you walk down that first part of
the hallway and it's open you can see
the freeway and then it comes comes left
and it's dead no windows anymore you
just see the hallway
shining carpet remember it was creepy as
well
yeah so I'm walking down the hallway I
don't know what it was I'm like oh [ __ ]
what's looking at me I'm like don't look
don't look don't look [ __ ] and like I
was too curious because I know my
grandma's on on some weird [ __ ] scene
[ __ ] like damn she passed it [ __ ] and
I'm like ah but it was more of my dreams
we talked about this where I see [ __ ] my
dreams don't happen it'll play out
Spiderman
and I'm like turn around but don't and I
get about two doors from my house and I
look back and there's this [ __ ] thing
like wearing sheets from the 20s is
[ __ ] thing smiling at me and he had
this big ass like clown shoes on and
he's smiling at me and I was like ah
come on [ __ ] and I turned around and
went in my house and then from that day
I was telling Rosie like yo
myself anymore like I don't want to go
to the hallway with myself anymore
because it scared the [ __ ] out of me and
my friend Matt
uh sheepdog [ __ ] genetics sheepdog
yeah Matt anyway um
we were walking in my apartment same
apartment it's like six months later
and I opened my [ __ ] door and I open
my door it's like someone [ __ ]
gorilla punched my [ __ ] blinds my
blind smacked the [ __ ] wall and
ceiling I just stopped
and I went mad you see that goes bro I
am looking at it
I know you saw it right like
I need to get some over here [ __ ]
someone needs to come by and get the
[ __ ] out of here and people like you're
[ __ ] high and Jim like then you live
with it [ __ ] you I'm high dripping then
but I was like that you saw it right
because Rosie came out the room where
was that go
[ __ ] now this shit's touch and [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then I had my homie whose mom's a
medium
uh I don't say his name but you know
what I'm talking about and she was like
she'll just give me the address I'll
look into it she looked in she goes yeah
a couple people died in a fire there in
the 20s a couple people got shot there
in the mugging I'm like
yeah what does that have to do with the
[ __ ] clown looking [ __ ]
sticker I have no idea I'm just letting
you know there's so much hostile [ __ ]
tension in that [ __ ] area that I
wouldn't live there I was like [ __ ] man
because remember I told him like I don't
want to walk to the [ __ ] car by
myself no more because I don't
it's not that Something's Gonna Hurt Me
I'm just like
um I hate this it's like walking in the
dark it's like swimming in the oceans
like a shark's in there but I'm not
gonna tell you when it's gonna buy he's
like uh uh so I'm like walking him oh
dude I hated my apartment my last
apartment it's like the rain
the other day I mean the other day I was
like how's that work bro
I I felt someone and I grabbed my chain
you know like yeah someone grabbed my
head too like I turned around I'm like
what the [ __ ] is nobody there
and then about 10 minutes later
um one of my assistants comes in and
she's just like oh that's a nice chain
OG and I'm just like huh what the [ __ ]
my chain was out and I'm like oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] it up
I just felt someone [ __ ] pull my
chain you know what I mean and and
[ __ ] and I've never had this chain
either because I mean it's just a silver
change I had to I had to change some
[ __ ] I was 17 years old you know I
just never I've never I've always wore
it no matter what so it's over 20 years
[ __ ] ad with this chain bro okay you
know so it was a trip because my chain
no one ever sees this chain nobody and
it was out and I was like what the [ __ ]
somebody [ __ ] pulled my [ __ ] chain
out right now
somebody touched my [ __ ] hair the
other day when I was walking in my
building oh yeah
yeah it's the first thing I thought was
like I get that uh you know what it was
in the building it was in the up it was
in the lobby you know it's an old
building [ __ ] it I'm good I'm good it's
just like you know what I mean because
I'm like damn dude why leave me the [ __ ]
alone
I hate that [ __ ] ever since I was a kid
man I [ __ ] hate it and then people
are like
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Music]
I'm going to get my nut hookers he
popped out of the [ __ ] closet
foreign
it's nothing wrong it's nothing bad it's
more you know what I'm thinking of it's
more of like
a reminder
yo stay on your toes [ __ ] that's
what I've been thinking someone touched
my [ __ ] hair the other day I was like
[ __ ]
damn it because I even took a look back
it's too silent behind me [ __ ] where are
you at [ __ ] that's all I kept
thinking like leave me the [ __ ] alone I
that's why I want to get in the house I
don't want to live in buildings anymore
yeah cause I'm tired of living around
everybody's [ __ ] energy and their
[ __ ] that they've dragged into
buildings with them it's life is really
Constantine and it's like yo just
[ __ ] be on your toes and be a good
person and don't do drugs I really
really really because I think when
people get on [ __ ] math and [ __ ]
they're just getting possessed bro I
think they put this he's like oh this
feels so [ __ ] up I'm gonna jump in
this [ __ ] that's a good that's
like a movie that's how I feel that's
the best time you can [ __ ] with you you
know what I mean and when you're done he
knows that right right there after okay
let's just say you do some math after
this five four days you've been up well
that's the best time you can [ __ ] with
you and guess what nobody's gonna
[ __ ] believe you because you're on
meds for real I know I'm sorry for
everyone out there going what is going
on and that's how when that's that's the
most time when he can take advantage and
[ __ ] what you really like you're vacant
yeah that's what I'm saying you're
vacant no it's real [ __ ] and I know
people are like yo what am I watching I
thought we were gonna have some funny
stories and stuff but yo this just
started it's another thing we just got
into like just started okay
um
so what we're saying is what is it
lately I feel like shit's been going off
lately I don't know what it is dude
but I feel I feel like she noticed all
the time is just even faster now of
course come on it's already three hours
shade off my day I don't know what's
going on lately yeah everything's just
moving loud we're moving a lot faster
something's up yeah I don't know what it
is but I feel it and I know a lot of
people like yeah me too and there's
gonna be paragraphs of people explaining
why I don't know what it is now I think
with all the social media there is no I
think now everybody's starting to see a
lot more and see like [ __ ] wait a minute
it's all [ __ ] I mean a lot of people
are [ __ ] you know you got the good
people that's done you know you got
people are starting to do good then you
got the people [ __ ] starting to do
bad now you know because they're like
[ __ ] this so and there's a community for
them to tap into for whatever type of
bad [ __ ] they're into yeah exactly now
you got you you got everything though
now this [ __ ] you want to be this [ __ ]
it go here you want to do this here you
go one is there you go all different
flavors there's all kinds of books yeah
yeah so wow hold on how long we've been
here real quick just real quick I say 47
minutes 15 okay we've only been two
questions we've been talking about
horrible things and like weird [ __ ]
let's get on to something super positive
the next question from hayden760 have
you ever been jumped
let's switch up the pace of violence and
hostility hold on hold on
have you ever been jumped and if so when
was the first time
buddy like yeah I've been jumped I've
been jumped once but it was almost like
it was dumb it was dumb I know he just
had a whole encyclopedia yeah which
paranormal stories you just shifted into
getting in the summer of my 18th year
was the best jumping I've ever had
that's how he just did it right now no
yeah I've got a job I mean I don't know
maybe uh
not by like a lot of them I want to say
like a lot of guys but maybe I think
maybe three three guys two guys maybe if
the most it happened once three and then
once twice two guys
um but this was all when I was younger
when I was maybe when I was you know
maybe about
14.
acknowledge that [ __ ] and turn it on
silent
oh my gosh
excuse me it says excuse me boss you
have a text message it said that since
I've known him but not even that he kept
talking like it wasn't his [ __ ] phone
I mean what do you mean don't go like
this
no but it's good we need one uh yeah
yeah but I mean back to game jump yeah
I've gotta jump uh [ __ ] one time I was
[ __ ] I was at a park and uh same [ __ ]
this was part of the reason why like I
said before you know why I've started
why I had to join the gang because I was
getting jumped because of [ __ ] you
know my family and who they were and it
was like [ __ ] it you're one of them and
you you know you're starting to dress
like one of them so you're okay and you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] it I would you know I you
know I would fight back it is what it is
it would beat me up too you know what I
mean because I had like three
[ __ ] on me and these ones were
back then they were older than me you
know what I mean I was like maybe 13
these schools were already like 17 16
they're older yeah so you know what I
mean so they were really interested you
know what I mean so you know if I can
just one day I got fed up and [ __ ] it I
got a hold of a gun they gave me a gun
and [ __ ] it I let these fools have you
know what I mean and you should uh
that's when to tell around this because
if this is the story I'm talking about
or that I'm thinking yeah so everything
yeah you know yeah I gotta jump [ __ ]
13 I got jumped right I think I got
jumped also
well when we went [ __ ] when we would
make these gangs up in school you mean
the preschool games you were making up
yeah you're running burritos
you know I would make gangs in the club
you know and seriously I mean we would
take you seriously we were seriously if
we seen one of them alone like going
[ __ ] you know what we just caught him
coming out of the [ __ ] taking his his
lunch late and he's coming out to go
hang out with boys
but yeah it's [ __ ] kids are getting
[ __ ] up in the lavatory yeah
you mean the bathroom yeah but no this
is your 90s in elementary school if you
see one of them kids go to the restroom
alone will be like look he's going in
the restroom we'll [ __ ] his ass up in
the restaurant like four or five of us
yo I'm sorry but I as if I was their dad
I'd [ __ ] kill all of you guys
real kid this is 80s we all had like
these little Mexican parents Spicer
parents you know what I mean you know
they weren't getting off work yet yeah
yeah they're [ __ ] working this is you
know I mean nowadays of course yeah you
had a whole pair of [ __ ] old video
you [ __ ] yeah yeah but back then [ __ ]
no and then there was moments where
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] up because and I
would do it attention like [ __ ] it I'm
not scared of these coolest thing and do
[ __ ] and yeah there's too many of them
[ __ ] like eight of them and they
[ __ ] all [ __ ] me up and I'll be
like [ __ ] you know damn I got my ass
kicked yeah but you know but then that's
in it was more like it was like it was
like uh like we're still cool with each
other we knew we were in classrooms you
guys weren't like knocking each other's
teeth out well [ __ ] bro if it happened
it did happen wait you guys are hitting
each other that hard we'll [ __ ] each
other up yeah man that sounds stupid no
it wasn't it was fun no it sounds it was
fun I mean right I mean I mean I mean
so bad so the next guy I catch I'm gonna
[ __ ] beat his ass up too I'm gonna
[ __ ] dead you know what I mean but
for one you know what um I'll be honest
you know wait I don't think there was
there was no face shots because that we
did but body shots and all that was on
it body shots rip your shirt kick them
anything you want to the body you're
good but no [ __ ] no [ __ ] faces
because then yeah then the parents would
probably want to come and be like hey
with my son but don't get me wrong there
was times where it slipped and the mom
would come be like my son has a black
guy and we'll be like [ __ ] well who did
it and then the kid will be oh no I hit
myself I told her but she thinks that
somebody beat me up
and [ __ ] it you know it was more like
that no it was pretty cool it was
actually fun so you're attributed to
gang violence in the 90s in Los Angeles
academically gang banging before you get
off to the neighborhood you know what's
crazy is you tell I'm not like my
brothers my family only at school bro
only that's cool like create gangs with
children
dressed like Genghis Khan with these
kids like what he was literally going no
give him your sandwich give me your
sandwich
that's him dude he's like break him down
building a backup of burritos and [ __ ]
right blessing the whole class
if you buy burritos in this class for
your food no no this is still this is
private school what I'm talking about
when I would get jumped no high school
[ __ ] no it never happened
oh okay okay this is private school like
what you're saying when I got jumped I I
got jumped in private school but you
know by our own [ __ ] other students
and then you know [ __ ] um
then at the parks you know enemies that
would see that we're getting along with
my family my enemies they were [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] me up too was that ring it
is what it is you know see that ring no
let me let me actually see it oh you win
I've never actually looked at it he
actually his name's Ray Finkel oh right
your name is Ray Finkel in the 80s right
well it's Ray Finkel the guy that come
on the guy from uh
right ace material remember the kicker
oh [ __ ] you're right bro if I forgot
about that one yo I've never actually
looked at this [ __ ] it's hard
is out
hold on hold on if I put this on watch
the glasses watch glasses pop on pop off
looks on looks off
that means my arm's not low no we
touched on now as a dad though
situations having to check kids check
parents check creeps trying to [ __ ] with
your kids
yeah okay yeah we've had incidents like
that all the time okay I've been
sixth grade fifth grade I think and
[ __ ] uh so we pull up to the school
and you know my kid I'm all like [ __ ]
but we're gonna go back and you're gonna
[ __ ] fight this kid and my kid's like
all right thank you so we go we walk you
through the library I'm like where's
this kid at oh [ __ ] and my son's all
like I don't know why he's looking for
him too and then after we finally we
spot him out but he's with his mom so
I'm like oh first I beat his mom's ass
you know yeah we walk up and we're like
hey you know what I mean like your kids
know they took my kid and you know
what's up and the mom was like what the
[ __ ] like she tripped down was she
Spanish no no you know but she's just in
the school with her kid no she was at
the library with her kid and and the
other parent was with her kid too so
they kind of tripped out the way I
pulled up like nah [ __ ] that they want
to fight my kid they're going to fight
right now yeah he's like what what do
you mean
right now like you know and I was just
like [ __ ] that you know I mean I mean
[ __ ] I was Furious you know I was mad
because I [ __ ] that bro you know we
make that's [ __ ] funny you know it's
one thing to press a parent on school
property which I've done before it's
another thing to be like nah now our
kids are gonna fight no no no no now
they're gonna fight yeah exactly no I
was pissed you're gonna [ __ ] so at
the end you know so we ended up talking
about and all that so we end up leaving
and right when we left that time I go
you know what I go you watch and see and
says I thought you watching see it Go
these are gonna be like his [ __ ]
little best friends or his good friends
sure enough nowadays now the kids over
my house sleeping you know what I mean
and then like I told her I go that's the
way it [ __ ] works trust me I like
some of my friends from back then that's
how we started you know [ __ ] hating
each other [ __ ] this guy and next thing
you know [ __ ] it we're [ __ ] good
friends and [ __ ] so I already had called
it bro and we tripped out because now
we're like [ __ ] you know didn't even
[ __ ] call this like it's a trip right
yeah yeah now they're like good friends
you know did the kids fart in that
moment what happened uh no they didn't
fight because you know we ended [ __ ]
all right well you know we end up
talking about it good but at the moment
I first pulled up I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you know bring back some
old school [ __ ] right now that's
hilarious
[ __ ] it I'm gonna bring back some old
school [ __ ] you know I mean it's just
like 2014 man yeah yeah it's not that
long ago you were an adult already yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah bro [ __ ] you get put
in these positions like like you don't
realize I mean I mean [ __ ] it's like you
you'll see bro you have your kids no
hide the Bush when they [ __ ] with your
kids yeah you know that's just that one
where it makes you feel like [ __ ] that
you know what I mean yeah you're not
gonna [ __ ] with my kids it's scary dude
because you know it's like
I might hit this kid hard I'll [ __ ]
it depends man it depends on what
happens like I might go to jail for this
all right I might have to wear a mask
because it's a terrifying the [ __ ] out
of this kid yeah and then yeah my thing
is I [ __ ] it
like you like to make you like [ __ ] that
who's their dad I don't [ __ ] the dad
yeah yeah because you know what I mean
like either dad didn't [ __ ] trade
this food right or didn't train her
right or whatever [ __ ] that you know
what I mean but that's what I would look
at right away [ __ ] it mm-hmm [ __ ] the
parents up yeah I mean um
it's good
it's good it's good
episode one when OG's like got him
yeah no no no it's good actually no no
no no no no it's good it's good it's
good [ __ ] it it's okay I finally bought
a pound when he likes it you just took a
hit of paper and I'll just give it a
couple hits oh it's been about to get
down you know to a quarter of it tastes
better you'll see
doesn't like black guys
it's okay dude this uh thumbnail is
gonna be me like this holding you
it's gonna be sick a little picture
about oh I have OG's baby picture too on
my phone I have a picture OG in 10th
Grade or no when he's like 10 years old
but I put 21 Savage tattoos all over his
face it's funny Luke Skywalker yeah with
your haircut he's got a [ __ ] straight
bowl cut bro
[ __ ] out of here he's got a Beatles cut
his [ __ ] god hey no but we did have
something Merry Christmas my parents
thought [ __ ] they were living in the
70s so all the 80s so they were dressed
me like a 70s kids bell bottoms and [ __ ]
were your parents hippies at all or what
were they like oh yeah some [ __ ]
Mexican hippies wait for real no [ __ ]
yeah probably from Mexico you know he's
traveled everywhere
[ __ ] yeah Mexico or some [ __ ] Bro cause
they had me all [ __ ] with the big old
collars and [ __ ]
like John Travolta yeah [ __ ] that me and
my brother were like [ __ ] look at those
[ __ ] I brought some big old [ __ ]
[Music]
I think I got it in my favorites
it's orange so it's not like I'm gonna
miss it
there it is I made this edit
oh my God
that looks like a [ __ ] fire mixtape
look at me can we see it right there
looks just like your son all this is
your son bro that's all I see is it's
hard yeah
[ __ ] I think I cut my own hair that day
shut the [ __ ] up yeah why because you're
pissed actually no they would they
wouldn't uh my my brother [ __ ] all
the time [ __ ] tell me oh you know
what if you want to go to the pool with
this you got to cut your hair because
you can't you don't let you in with long
hair oh [ __ ] ass they won't let you
in because you have long hair because
they didn't want to take me so I'm like
oh is that right [ __ ] that went in the
restroom I got the scissors
started cutting my hair I go now can I
go and they're like what they all
started laughing dedication they took
you on so they took me yeah yeah
you're down as [ __ ] yeah they took me oh
yeah and I cut my hair gosh all [ __ ]
up and now you're like yesterday was
like two days later I remember my mom
was mad so she just made me go like
whatever I think after that that's when
I started weighing whatever the [ __ ] I
wanted to you start telling that when
you like eat emotions and [ __ ] but you
could come in bro but you got to be bald
you know you gotta be bald to come in
and watch him shave his foot his brother
looks like uh
[ __ ] come on okay [ __ ] it from uh come
on come on for Saturday Night Live come
on your brother looks like come on no he
looks a lot like homeboy [ __ ] I feel
so dumb what was that one remember that
movie [ __ ] younger no I feel wacky
what's his name
he has jokes about the hair from
Saturday Night Fever for sure okay but
he looks like oh I feel weak as hell I
know that motherfucker's name is from
you should Google it like one of the
actor's name in the movie Sidekicks with
Chuck Norris
no I think he looks a lot like [ __ ]
homeboy [ __ ] uh that doesn't help me
bro the black guy records out on uh what
time Arnold Schwarzenegger uh jingle
jingle all the way you talking about
Sinbad yeah
but his brother looks nothing like
Sinbad I just there
Joe Piscopo he looks like your brother
looks like young Joe Piscopo from second
Saturday life damn he looks like a white
dude yeah he looks white if you have a
mustache and tattoos and locks
like yo you're a median yeah yeah for
sure I don't think our OG is looking
like a white dude because of his goatees
I'm saying he didn't have his look his
light skin is [ __ ] yeah his brother's
white as hell his brother's light
skinned as hell okay all right and he's
got a little pompadours thing Joe
piscopal thing going on he does not look
like a Mexican but he [ __ ] talk to
him
like oh okay okay Rocco did the whole
transformation too I was like this looks
like a different [ __ ] kid yeah he
looked like a white kid and he looked
like a Mowgli for a while and then now
he looks whatever he looks like uh-huh
damn you can play Mowgli damn you can
play like really adolescent Mogul hey
brother he looks wild oh your little
brother
really no
to this conversation yeah I did bro
Mowgli my brother now
um okay so yeah your brother definitely
does not look like Sinbad
it's crazy that you think he looks nice
maybe on that movie he does jingle all
the way maybe on that movie because
Let's Take a Shot we haven't taken a
shot or nothing got a [ __ ] bottle
over here let's go [ __ ]
okay
go grab my dick real quick grab my dick
real quick that's the new damn I haven't
said that in a long time what's wrong
that was the new [ __ ] like that was my
new [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] everybody everybody
out there even girls especially girls
instead of saying yo I have to go pee
real quick or at home I'm gonna go to
the bathroom just say what's really true
if you're a guy like yo I'm gonna go
grab my dick real quick because that's
literally what you're gonna go do like
I'll move yeah I'm gonna pee also and
wash my hands but I don't have to it's
funnier if you leave that part out hey
I'm gonna grab my dick real quick girls
start saying all right before we like to
join oh let me grab my dick real quick
oh that's why we said it because I was
about to lie to join he goes hold on let
me go to the bathroom like
so basically let me go touch my dick oh
let me go touch my dick real quick
that's what it was and I'm gonna touch
my dick real quick that's what it was
yeah he coined that no I did a Mike yo
so basically you're saying let me go
touch my dick and then let's touch this
joint and put it in my mouth thanks
thank you you're a critical thinker yeah
that's basically what happens uh did you
take the shot touch about your dick and
never even said anything no no actually
I took a little shot so yes so you did
so you did let's go we're celebrating
our eminent bills right it's Monday
Night Football tonight
as we sit here oh as it's playing like
that it is [ __ ] Saturday yes Titans
bills Titans bills Marty's gonna be an
announcer one day how was that listen I
when I sit there and watch the UFC it's
weird like the [ __ ] I say Echoes from
the [ __ ] announcers because I've been
listening so long it's like I know what
they're gonna [ __ ] say it's like
you're talking to April right now no
what I'm saying is I need their job I'm
more charismatic I'm taller I'm stronger
yo we need April to just sit in she's my
[ __ ] no she's like this is weird she
even says it no I'm not saying that I'm
saying in general yeah you guys don't
believe each other for anything no
should be my like when they just live
together
she's she's
[ __ ] probably play basketball and
[ __ ] too
are you gonna describe her for soccer
she could probably run longer than both
of us man I'm just looking for some
proof I just watched that episode back
hilarious because
you're married to her yeah I was looking
for some proof I'm sorry I'm trying to
help your name out here your athlete in
the household so cam
we had a nice 7-2 Victory today
oh yeah
sorry about the ass Mr drinking sounds
um oh gee go take your dick real quick
go pee we will be right back I'm gonna
bring the mic yeah bring the mic yeah
little ass mister
all right now that we're back now that
we're you gonna take a shot too yeah no
yeah for sure yeah no
oh [ __ ] it's time I'm so [ __ ] saying
us now are you
do you want one Marty are you good uh
you're the Miller I'll take uh I'll take
the light whisper a light whisper let me
get your cup
a light whisper I never heard that one
before here
that's ASMR there you go there's a light
Whisperer
hey you you're not driving right
for sure I am
for you know laws and purposes let's say
you want to uh grab the Carla
I will over here in a second for sure
got some joints no one even take the
shots what's up what's up let's take
them
to another [ __ ] legendary
episode all right here we go now that
we're back because OG's bladder was just
he's like no I can't do it bro I haven't
got Justin
right now
two minutes
you ready yes first it's what serious
about two minutes I don't know maybe
four minutes here we go
boom
ah it's delicious
it barely tastes like alcohol
or he doesn't get affected by this [ __ ]
that tastes like just a regular dress
expensive like it wasn't [ __ ] OG's over
there [ __ ] it's good doing the same
thing no that's that show tastes
expensive it's just me
I'm good off that liquor [ __ ]
chill into my teeth never drink liquor
oh thank you all right here we go now
that we're back what the [ __ ] were we
talking about
man this is man we're all over the place
we are all over the place this is the
haziest episode of all time we decided
yeah and we're not even we're not even
not even done all right I'm ready to get
back into it are you sure you're ready
let's start this off I asked you right
when we sat down what the [ __ ] do you do
to your finger finger the finger that
splice oh [ __ ] split open yeah this was
just uh
oh gee stabbed a guy trying to teach oh
she stabbed the guy with his finger I
was trying to teach a [ __ ] um
no just some [ __ ] [ __ ] on the stairs
he's taking out what do you call those
[ __ ] sandpapers the grip tape on the
stairs [ __ ] I was standing right [ __ ]
it he came back no he's he came to me
he's all like hey sorry is it cool if I
do this tomorrow like why he goes it
took me 15 minutes to just do one I'm
like what the [ __ ] so I went out there
and just [ __ ] let me see this [ __ ]
[ __ ] did in 30 seconds boom ripped
around I'm like [ __ ] this 30 seconds off
he's like how'd you do that or I don't
know what he told me [ __ ] I did
another one and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] just [ __ ] I missed
the [ __ ] the paint scrapers [ __ ]
went straight to my finger and [ __ ]
sliced it open
a little kid was like oh [ __ ] I could
see the inside of your [ __ ] here your
[ __ ] it's open I was like [ __ ] out of
here go it's your [ __ ] phone my
energy backhanded him with his bloody
hand look what you look what you do
[ __ ] just no it's so white still it's
like me and then the blood comes out and
I was like [ __ ] it didn't even start to
bleed till like maybe about I want to
say about maybe 30 seconds later oh yeah
it takes aside those are the bad ones
you can see the vein everything you said
you stitched that [ __ ] up uh this one I
know I put those uh what do you call
those [ __ ] liquid stitches no I put
that liquid bandage in the glue some
glue and then no I put those what do you
call those [ __ ] those little
butterfly ones little butterfly oh yeah
yeah butterfly stitches things [ __ ]
closed it up damn that [ __ ]
it's just a certain type of like bandage
okay you're calling it stitches it was
fresh so I just [ __ ] boom Oh geez
over the [ __ ] really with the needle
no he's not dude it's just a baby [ __ ] I
could have done it if I would have
needle I've done it before but when did
you Stitch yourself up you like doing
[ __ ] I could like somebody get shot you
bring them to OG did you stitches one of
my own ways of a [ __ ] got shot he got
raised and uh [ __ ] he came in and
[ __ ] all that what happened he's like
oh [ __ ] we just got shot at right now
come in your house I was like what the
[ __ ] yeah he was great so he had a
good [ __ ] Grace on his [ __ ] so
[ __ ] I don't know who had it we had a
like a army [ __ ] kid or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] stitched him up
you just figured it out yeah just no I
mean I just just from me getting
stitches or seeing something you know
seeing the stitches all the way doing it
yeah it was like a little hook [ __ ] it
he was hurting but was he [ __ ]
freaking out while you're sitting there
I can't remember actually not because
that [ __ ] was pretty deep it was [ __ ]
he was still laying out a lot of blood
like it was just did you get them oh it
just he grazed him so yeah I mean [ __ ] I
mean don't get me wrong hey
it got infected but it got infected
because of him not [ __ ] being clean
with it you know what I mean if he would
have kept it clean he would have been
good it's like with me with this one I
kept the [ __ ] clean you know yeah you'll
die from that [ __ ]
it's sealed like no pain is done you
know I mean it's like perfect but it is
who I don't know what he did he got
infected and [ __ ] has there been any
really well they were tripping nice
where the [ __ ] did this to you yeah but
[ __ ] it yeah at dtpg with all the
[ __ ] machinery and [ __ ] are like
people [ __ ] themselves up often or
not so much oh at the shop um no
actually I couldn't see yourself wait
for myself
and [ __ ] but accidents do happen we've
had I've seen some accidents seen some
dude fall out of the [ __ ] just come
down out of the roof like nowhere
how far you fall from the very very top
it felt pretty high
not that high but I'm a worker hide a
[ __ ] yeah bro [ __ ] you up wow
remember that one time I was doing a
video on your roof and I was like yo
this is indestructible weed bag I'm
gonna throw it off the roof let me know
if there's humans coming by remember
that and then I threw it off and as I'm
throwing like no no and I almost cracked
that person in the [ __ ] skull there
was an ounce inside of it there's an
ounce jar inside of it what do you mean
which one I've landed at their feet
remember that time I was standing on the
roof and told you and Rosie let me know
if there's a person coming I'm gonna
throw this bag off your roof
with all my wheat [ __ ] in it to see if
the bag works and as I'm throwing you
guys are all stop oh yeah I almost
killed that [ __ ] person
[Music]
somebody
destructible yeah it would have cracked
the person look at her Randy Moss that
[ __ ] if it was gonna come down to it uh
all right this dude came out of nowhere
he's just like I don't know where he
decided to get off the [ __ ] Garden
start walking by it was on a bike
oh imagine you if you'd have just died
wait so you're talking about this was at
your apartments at the da Vinci's right
no no you're dtpg right now oh [ __ ] I'm
thinking about the one at your house
didn't you doing at your house too or no
no at the after [ __ ] balcony
yeah but not with you
that was a video yeah
okay well okay so here's the video too I
remember yeah yeah that was like okay I
remember yeah the jar the indestructible
Journey yeah you were you were hacking
it was a knife yeah
yeah what are the odds of that [ __ ] Bro
the bad word I had a Rambo knife
they looked at me though yeah it was
[ __ ] two of the afternoon
this was [ __ ] tweaked the [ __ ] well
yeah and he's filming it normal they're
just like that they didn't even got a
camera man yeah yeah
Hood Vlogs and [ __ ] exactly what was
going on dude that's just funny okay so
that's what we're talking about you
chunked your damn hand and then you
sewed your friend's arm to an infection
no I saw this late it wasn't his arm you
said his arm right did he say sorry
Oh I thought you said he got Grays oh
yeah he got grades I was just like I was
trying to Oh I thought you meant he got
no different dude that than the dude
that got shot in the bottom of the foot
yeah okay oh yeah that was his brother
my brother okay cool
he'd be home
all right so do you have you have
another fan question you said dude we're
we're kind of just like we've we didn't
want to like ask like so
85 questions about stories because we've
done we've done so many story stories
that we're kind of just yeah take this
episode as we were as we're going to
watch YouTube just do you like when
you're sitting at the office do you just
like sit and watch here like recommend a
page no you know what I'm not gonna lie
no I mean I I watch I watch YouTube just
as there's certain certain things that
do it for and then just for for you know
watch my son here and yeah
so you don't watch like he sits around
and watches like fighting and [ __ ] Tick
Tock he's on Tick Tock okay watching
crazy I just started getting into
graffiti videos people with the pen
markers like yeah like those there's
some sick ass [ __ ] channels yeah is
there any like random [ __ ] you like to
sit and watch
um if I do I like to do more like uh
meditation or [ __ ] yeah
that's that's fine that's what little
raw videos and meditation videos oh um
fki first put us on to the I did that
[ __ ] he was like you can see frequency
that you sleep too you can sleep too and
you can listen too yeah I saw some alarm
clock recently guys
I also like what man Mantra also same
thing right what a mantra Mantra yeah
right like something you said that's
like a chant yeah no he's talking about
meditation I'll I'll put that oh you
look at that [ __ ] God you got you
[ __ ] you know I know I know that [ __ ]
helps me out
what happens when you're scared under
the blankets waiting for me to get home
from work with my tie hey son how was
your day sorry I was watching some
stupid ass ABC Family Show Rosie that's
how I felt like hi
remembering Breakfast Club what are you
talking about hi son yes Dad when that
falls pumpkin Emilio Estevez that's me
and you
ask OG where he got this burn from
where'd you get that burn from maybe you
spilled paint in my garage and I burned
you with a cigar talk about breakfast
club still man what the [ __ ] you see
this
sorry everyone everybody under 30 didn't
get that [ __ ] right now my bad my bad
hey guys remember you still painting the
crash that's you
you're Judd Nelson hey you know what
wait what what were you gonna say
something super dumb
you really do already
hold on we got some [ __ ] to introduce
how about this how about this magic go
pee go touch your dick real quick and
I'll have something for you when you
come back
yeah
I touch my neck then I grabbed my worm
and then I roll the blind
oh you're back
sure sure you're back have you recording
the whole time yeah baby stop all right
you're back
what were we talking about
so we're talking about
um
Thomas
we were talking about YouTube no oh yeah
there you go thank you the only person
that's on track here
I was literally asking I forgot who
we're talking about uh now if we were to
go into like your Spotify or apple music
what would be like the most played uh
things that we would find in there my
pinky ring I saw your daughter I mean I
mean I had my categories like if I'm you
know in the morning I like to listen to
oldies
you know what I mean my own kind of work
and then when I'm off work
I like to listen to you know some rap
90s [ __ ] maybe even a new [ __ ] Edison I
[ __ ] up with 21 Savage it's usually
when my socks are kind of high
[ __ ] here and there you know what I mean
some of this [ __ ] well I'm gonna hear
this man a couple bumps at 24. you got
so much music now it's like [ __ ] you
know what I mean but I mean I started
some of his first [ __ ] he brought out
and uh [ __ ] just [ __ ] what biggie
[ __ ] Tupac [ __ ] you know all those
cool [ __ ]
do you find yourself listening to mainly
the same old [ __ ] like circling
backstage don't do that like that old
Funk [ __ ] you know [ __ ] Africa
bambaata and [ __ ] you know what I mean
from Planet Rock you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that you know if you grew up doing
drugs in the 80s 90s that kind of music
yeah pretty much I like all that old
school even older NWA [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] with that pretty much mainly I mean
[ __ ] I mean lately now I've been just
listening to classical music [ __ ] on
my way home especially when I get off at
night that's that's nice smashing a
[ __ ] Beamer listen to pianos no
actually 15 15 minutes and I actually
keep it cool when I [ __ ] listen to
something like [ __ ] classical [ __ ]
just driving I'm gonna try that I like
Italian music like [ __ ] you'd hear it
like Olive Garden but like
yeah
you know what I mean I can say it's like
some that's like medicine for the brain
you know what I mean when you hear your
family
you know some Italian [ __ ] like all of
the [ __ ] they play an Olive Garden when
I was a kid I was crazy I didn't realize
Olive Garden is where we went for my
birthday like Olive Garden was a fancy
yeah like we joke to Modesto to go to
the Olive Garden yeah okay cool all
right
like [ __ ] the level above McDonald's
dude merced's so hyped we're getting an
Olive Garden
well you guys are people are Heights
okay I love small town bro we're a small
town Brad's takes to the raspberry
lemonade Galore um there you're trying
to gain weight let's go to Olive Garden
so everybody still calls the scissors
over there
100 that is the popping spot we don't
have a Cheesecake Factory yeah we gotta
we got a Applebee's
is the nightclub bro really I swear to
God people and like went to high school
with me go to Applebee's for like happy
hour like it's a nightclub oh [ __ ] yo
we're a small town we're a small town
man so it's the same [ __ ] you know
everyone's a little behind you know what
I mean yeah like I said I said 10 years
behind I always say that with game [ __ ]
with all that [ __ ] they're 10 years back
everything no getting in all right all
right getting into it because back in
days that's not what it is that's not I
said that's not what it is nothing
racial with it now now it's [ __ ] you
know but back there it wasn't it's not
even a racial term
this is drunk
with that being said I'm gonna bust
something out on you real quick before
we start this up you have little baby
tiny lungs our side of the family you
should have got my jeans with the big
lungs I don't know why you didn't get
much so what I'm trying to say is hit
this bong think about it you're scared
look at it closely is that what you're
about to say to me look son I'm I'm
um
age that's not true
metaphysically do you really believe
that you're double my [ __ ] games
what well I met you I was like [ __ ]
24.
I've known you for almost a decade and I
always forget my son's birthday and [ __ ]
okay that's a good one that was good old
email he's got a couple kids out here in
these streets that's why my son was only
27. yeah I bet he looks [ __ ] 24.
what's wrong with do you think I'm
double your you think you're 60
six he's a wise man out here he's no no
wait 10 years in these streets I am 33
years old
33. okay 33. all right so 33. you met me
when I was like a child yeah yeah okay
you're right but but you were also like
33 when I met you so come on man okay so
yeah all right
still it doesn't help the situation
you're off as [ __ ] continue
baby lungs and I always forget your
birthday when you're a kid yeah your
little baby lungs and you don't like to
smoke smoke bongs anymore because like
oh it's not the 90s anymore because I
mean it's just a random coincidence I
don't know I feel the Lord at work here
we're debuting these beautiful pieces of
Machinery the last time you know we did
we did a [ __ ] we did that podcast
right oh that was scary let's go that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up bro I was [ __ ] it's
because you're scared the difference you
know like I always did it of course
they're different it's not a giant what
do we have here this year I don't like
the higher you know what I mean because
you're scared and you have anxiety
scared my ass watch watch you ready
ready when you hit this ball he'll shake
so hard his mustache
it'll shake like that it'll start
ticking like hook yeah like
exactly this is a brand new ball we're
introducing right now
do me a favor
just put your eye down that and look for
some reason
it looks extra hard
it looks pretty cool that's a good
picture right yeah good picture let's go
please drop these bongs and you're gonna
hit it let me see you you're gonna hit
it look down look down the barrel it's
with the color it's with the color look
it took your glasses off bull
it's dark in there what are you guys
talking about
um
it looks sick I guess I guess
it's being all bashful and [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is fire it's all right now these
things hey oh we aren't quite available
no it's not at all it doesn't have the
same pattern that's the walls I didn't
notice that I didn't just to [ __ ]
right now see that's girl these are new
that's it that's that new hot [ __ ] we're
doing about looking down at this [ __ ]
what I'm saying it's dope as [ __ ]
you're gonna tell me you guys don't do
this at home when you clean your bongs
you don't do this of course of course
you do right
of course it's stupid that's where all
the goobers live yeah that's because
you're scared no man
scared you're scared I ain't got a
[ __ ] it's brand new glass brand new
glass never even been hit long rips
every damn day I'll be [ __ ] [ __ ]
up oh buff if y'all buffing taller
and we're gonna make you rip it
and don't hey you're on camera listen to
him
did the bathroom breaker yeah
you'll be okay don't worry I'll give you
a little baby giant Bowl
don't worry you'll be okay your name's
OG not no G
this [ __ ] guy that's okay
we should have put him on the bong with
the logs with the fitted with the goatee
just the silhouette yeah oh that'd be
hard he should be what's on the bottom
oh just just hit me when you look
through it yeah here hit this
because man you're our guest this is an
honorary type of thing we're putting on
right remember that song Be Our Guest
from uh Beauty and the Beast
that's what song plays when OG walks
into my house let's go he's the most
returned screws on the most no if you
feared you gotta like you concentrate
real and it just block pops together did
you use mind mind power oh so you gotta
push yeah you gotta ignite the flower
with your mind
I have a feeling you might break that do
me a favor don't Smack it against this I
see it listening I see it happening bro
I don't know why I see it happening
no because he will do that he will do
that though he's not gonna go you're
looking at him
that's what he'll say exactly
look he's turning away from the camera
because he doesn't want the camera to
know that no no hold on and every time
he hits the ball he ends up ripping the
whole thing like like it's not hard the
Jedi yes I don't understand you could do
this hands-free right now if you wanted
to
oh you're scared let's go I'm scared
hold on excuse me
he can't hear you cheering for him on
the soundboard
because he doesn't like to wear it
what'd he say earlier it makes it makes
me look susceptible to to violence
that's what you said I was kidding he
literally said I can't put headphones on
I feel like I'm taking off to the Moon
yeah it's a bong man I was just making
you hit it because you're scared of
Bones
um
Marty what's the next question and first
bomb ribs on the podcast by the way
technically especially out of our own
[ __ ] you have our own [ __ ] yeah so you
just got those it's the first time we
just said it's a first person hitting it
really so nobody you haven't put them
out there yet
Rick Rick James rewind it yeah I'm
grinding my feet and Eddie's couch do
that to him
oh first ball oh okay
okay I remember grinding my feet and
Eddie's couch
that's you [ __ ] your couch that's you
hold on
oh here we go
[ __ ] your couch
good timing man good timing man and then
this is gonna be me and you after and
I'm Bob Barker in this situation I'm
gonna win
I'm gonna win these are good stickers
Marty thank you
yeah thank you bad questions let's go
hold on we got about 10 000 [ __ ]
questions [ __ ] all right so hold on hold
on real quick
oh gee
what do you think the Raiders real quick
what do you think the Raiders career as
a football team in the National Football
Team league is going to look like this
year what's that record looking like six
and one
I mean [ __ ] okay
I already know what the [ __ ] ain't
nothing [ __ ] new or nothing [ __ ] it
it is what it is I said you left me
[ __ ] don't lie you're a [ __ ]
Raider fan too
you stay loyal to the Raiders amidst all
the moves he was a Cowboy fan when I met
him oh [ __ ]
I mean I don't give a [ __ ] I mean it's
Sports bro I don't think it's too
personal like to a fact where like the
people that get all [ __ ] want to
offended and want to start [ __ ] break
your chest piece [ __ ] you know what I
mean even if I do get my [ __ ] rated I
don't know man you can't take it that
far from him okay you know what I mean
it is what it is so Sports you care
about you got the Dodgers you got the
Raiders is that where it stops Raiders
USC oh okay so who do you like in the
UFC USC U.S oh [ __ ] no he's only La
teams basically what he's saying [ __ ]
okay anything from L.A [ __ ] with USC
[ __ ] um Raiders Dodgers Lakers
you know the usual [ __ ]
um
that's it probably I appreciated your
crap your enthusiasm for that Big Bill's
Victory last week he just hates the
ramps you guys [ __ ] the Rams good he
hates the Raptors I don't know bro
I mean I know for the real Ram fans I
[ __ ] yeah I look for them cool but you
got so much [ __ ] fake ass [ __ ]
people now they [ __ ] up who's the real
La team who do real what team do real
L.A people playing
I mean [ __ ] it I mean is it the writers
oh when it comes yeah Raiders [ __ ] yeah
they take over alley all the [ __ ]
time bro no matter what no matter
[ __ ] what
they hate it they don't want to [ __ ]
hear it but they [ __ ] we [ __ ] feel
weird so nobody the Chargers the Rams
like I don't see I've never seen some
like Ram [ __ ] out no way oh they don't
care they don't give a [ __ ] St Louis
team it's because you know
how many Raiders Super Bowls were in L.A
the one so you buy his ass [ __ ]
same exact situation as the LA Rams then
oh no for sure no I mean still don't get
me wrong that's not like a [ __ ] like
something but I I say they don't got the
fan base yet of course not that's not
you [ __ ] don't you know what I mean I
agree with you but I just like the bias
in your in you oh the reason I was
laughing so hard is I am your father
literally because it sounds just like
dark damn that's why I was laughing I'm
like oh geez
that's too [ __ ] awesome you you
[ __ ] up you had the bong first and you
could have said it to me but forever I'm
your dad now because of this movie it's
true I'm older than you why sir taller
Darth Vader divorce Darth Vader voice my
mustache comes in thicker
I shaved it twice today yeah as soon as
we know what this ad reads it's going to
be full force beard again that's like
Homer yeah yeah when that's what the P
brick was about exactly exactly I had to
shave again I don't want I didn't want
to embarrass my son
so now you you and your wife have been
together for a while
a while right yeah 20
some years so Gabrielle Flores here what
would be maybe your best piece of advice
for a young couple coming up in today's
world
for long to stay together longevity
take care of your ladies man that's it I
mean [ __ ]
you gotta take care of it you know what
I mean like that doesn't describe it at
all you can't let your lady work what no
you know that's a dumbest shower [ __ ]
life
you gotta take care of your lady
don't look at her don't look at her
so if you want to send your lead to an
environment where you know she's gonna
[ __ ] no matter what you can get you
know it's gonna happen you know I mean
if you don't like that then [ __ ] damn
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] take care of them
yeah that's that's just been my [ __ ] I
mean my dad worked my dad always works
my mom never worked that's the way I got
I grew up seeing it as my mom always
home taking care of us and doing this
and that that's why I think maybe that's
when we're gangsters fool well I mean
but I mean because yeah of course we're
like more like that you know [ __ ] our
parents were like [ __ ] you know
spices and [ __ ] they didn't give a
[ __ ] as long as they send us to that
private school they thought oh and he's
doing good but [ __ ]
but I grew up watching all that and
seeing my mom always at home so I mean I
just took after it I mean no disrespect
I get it there's people out there that
where where the girl works on that's
cool fine but I mean as for me as a man
[ __ ] them I don't want mainly the Optics
I know what's out there so our [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] rather number one yeah
I'm checking the box of paying for
everything exactly you know until this
day like my my wife never worked she
never worked the day in her life you
know what I mean and I've always [ __ ]
took care of it I mean that's just been
my thing I don't know yeah [ __ ] reach
their own [ __ ] that's cool I respect
it no respect cool I know girls got to
work my daughter's working [ __ ] I'm
gonna tell my daughter's don't worry
because you're gonna go find a man
that's gonna take care of you [ __ ] I
tell another book but that's just what I
grew up seeing in my household you know
my mom never works my parents did math
yeah I mean that's what I just did I
mean they took care of that yeah
so basically you say don't let your
girlfriend go outside because she might
get hit on by another human being no
[ __ ] bro what I took from that I
actually like my little brother like
that you could look at the Devils
everywhere bro but let me handle guys
looking at your profile what are you
looking at you just don't [ __ ] want I
mean I mean I'm just saying [ __ ] yeah as
a man what about like two incomes an
independence [ __ ] it then you know what
I mean but I mean [ __ ] reach their own
right [ __ ] but I mean how far does that
go though like with just letting her out
into the world oh she go of course
you know fighting each other all good
just don't let her [ __ ] out the house
when you're not home is what I'm hearing
from you guys okay that's what you're
saying to me really [ __ ] weirdo I'm
saying what's the relationship advice
take care of them don't let her work
what about like communicating and being
friends
an hour later
it's all good and you have the Scarface
mentality
another quaaludence you'll love me in
the morning that's what you're saying
okay I guess what you're saying it's
quick not ignorant I get it I [ __ ] with
it I mean that's all part that's that's
that's what that's what comes with you
know
shut the [ __ ] up shut up shut up yo for
the eight girls watching this
[ __ ] Wild
I'm yo you know what's crazy is my dad
dissing [ __ ] like said some [ __ ] like
that but he was serious when I was a
child I'm like y'all may be four years
old but you're [ __ ] dumb as hell man
that's how I thought my whole life
you know my dad I know I remember I was
like before I went to school my Dad
tried
my dad dressed me like a flannel shirt I
was like bro yeah what the [ __ ] but I
remember like
he was telling me like you see somebody
you don't go hi what's up you do this
I remember he'd like do it I'm like put
my chin up I was before [ __ ]
preschool he's like yeah you see a
friend you don't say hi across the
street you go like that and you put your
hands up too I'm like Dad I'm not doing
that that's that's stupid like a San
Andreas character thank you like when
you don't press the controls for a while
[ __ ] yeah that's talking my dad
basically said to egg you do this and if
they're real far you can do it longer
like the [ __ ] what what comedian said
that what comedian said that it was like
a bit I feel like I said but my dad told
me that as a child but there's a I feel
like there's a comedian that said that
like you just do this that's literally
what my dad told me he's like and
they're far you just go longer like you
can say what's up or you whistle my
dad's from the North like the [ __ ]
Norteno whistle you try to teach me as a
kid and [ __ ] damn my dad was mad
ignorant dude yeah I can't whistle like
that do it I can't whistle like that
it's loud when I hear that whistle I
know like oh
oh some [ __ ] Section 8 [ __ ]
rolling his eyes at his dad trying to
teach him how to do this 100 like I told
you before we started like I've been
that's the dumbest [ __ ] I ever heard bro
I'm not gonna go
I'm gonna go hey what's up Brandon like
I'm not gonna do that I was I was going
into preschool or to kindergarten he
said that's how you're supposed to say
hi to your friends
ugh my dad also was 23.
so all right I'll give him that but I
remember he's like yeah you just do this
you put your hands out and say what's up
I've never heard of somebody thinking
these actions out so much like bro it's
not even that because it's when I say it
out loud it's like more like
could have swore I've heard that on a
stand-up somewhere too and when I heard
I go that's what my [ __ ] Dad tried to
tell me I feel like it's George Lopez it
has to be dude somebody in the comments
is gonna know exactly what stand up it
is it has to be dude because it was too
popular but I hear my dad told me that
like yo you're ignorant
and I mean my actual dad and my son see
that's why he doesn't do it I never
taught him like he never does that he
says hello how you doing he holds doors
good manners I taught him it's [ __ ]
good
it takes you so long to catch under
what's [ __ ] happening that's the best
part about this is the fact that you're
like
oh me yeah what about you the guest
damn what are we talking about
oh relationship advice then you went all
[ __ ] 1945
okay yeah yeah I feel you I'm just
saying look I mean I don't know I've
just I see
I just kind of carried it I'm pretty
sure my kids are not gonna you know
carry that needed I'm not trying to push
it to them it's just what I've seen what
I picked up on him oh yeah and then
Scarface thing I didn't find the same
[ __ ]
like I always knew like my protector was
always my mom for some reason I always
say you know and that's the way when I
had kids that's the way I wanted my kids
to feel like [ __ ] that I want the same
thing you know what I mean because she
can't be out working and my kids gonna
be like you know [ __ ] games [ __ ] that
bro so I always took care of my girl so
she could always take care of my kids so
that that was my thing you know for my
kids so they could grow up that's fine
but the fact that you're like I don't
want [ __ ] hitting on her [ __ ]
there's evil out there
but that's also comes with it
the way I always see it is this when all
whenever fools are like getting mad like
it's my girl fool like yo I saw her by
herself just like you did when you met
and you approached her probably [ __ ]
people always get like shot over that
[ __ ] it's like bro your girlfriend's
pretty I thought she was single so I
went to talk to her she's alone you know
how many times people get my [ __ ] yeah
my little brother martin bro
I hope he's over it but oh my God he's
he oh my God just ruthless I had to tell
him all the time like sometimes people
aren't staring at you there might be
like a chick she's staring at behind you
not everyone wants to shoot you stop
shooting people like stop doing stupid
[ __ ] it's a long time ago he's okay
little brother's [ __ ] be wild as hell
my brother martin yeah not for my dad he
grew up dumb
he grew up [ __ ]
dumb it's doing stupid stupid [ __ ] but
you know what I mean he's same [ __ ] like
you do like don't be looking over there
like bro I was just shut up sorry your
wife was behind the cereal I was trying
to [ __ ] out of here I know I don't do
this
you don't catch yourself just pressing
random civilians and [ __ ] over uh no I
mean I look at I'm about respect look if
like if we're somewhere [ __ ] yeah you
know the casino at a club or something
if a girl comes up to hang up to your
lady I mean I mean I don't give a [ __ ]
you mean a guy next to it yeah I'm gonna
check this food that's different yummy
yeah it comes with the territory of this
show that's different
April's allowed to work
yeah I mean to my point I'm [ __ ] with
you at this point I know what you're
saying what he's saying his goals for
dudes though like that's that's the real
thing I told her the same thing but I
want to work enough to where you don't
have to do anything yeah if you want to
yeah I start that side business what the
[ __ ] do whatever you want yeah
start that [ __ ] okay 100 yeah do that
[ __ ] but I mean it's difficult like I
said I grew up different [ __ ] I
always just started [ __ ] it micro's
never gonna have to work you know what I
mean do you want to fight
do you want a box right now domestic
dispute father son fight I'm sorry for
hitting you have to be your buddy
Offspring [ __ ] table do you like The
Offspring the band The Offspring what do
you like the band The Offspring remember
them
right they were named after you when I
had you though yo you just had some
Offspring I was like yes that's it he's
all you can do it that Spanish song it
was about him like yo your baby came out
with a mustache and a goatee I was like
yeah and looks
and Cortez's damn I thought you're
talking about water boy no I'm just
talking about nothing at this [ __ ]
point I don't know what were you
geez that was a mother you see his face
he licks the graph I gotta wash it down
all his hats with some water now I did
before it I just got it now because
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you up you'll
be all right you'll be okay
um I I don't know what we're about to
LEAP into I forgot I'm very sorry no
because I know there was another fan
question that we got in the relationship
[ __ ] and it went [ __ ] left yeah yeah
okay no
OG's a gamer correct oh no OG plays
games and loses and plays them a lot he
I would consider him a gamer Enthusiast
that gaming enthusia it's like an
abusive relationship
like Norbit [ __ ] the game is his wife
okay hold on what you play what PS5 or
you want a PC okay you're on PS5
and are you playing like all different
kinds of games or mainly just the same
like one to three usually I just stick
to three games
and yeah what are those oh my God how
the [ __ ] is your phone back on
bro turn it on silence something weird
going on with these phones I saw you
clicking on but I thought you were
kidding
why would you keep it on still
oh my God
what's wrong with you money calls when I
call that's not it it's a text from one
of his [ __ ] kids that you could just
just put on silent my sister oh thanks
for clarifying Mindy can also hold your
phone and go hey child
he's literally on camera right now on
silent though
you could do that too yeah no my bad
yeah yeah you know what nobody heard it
now we didn't hear it anymore all right
top three on the PS5
on Call of Duty how would you describe
your style are you a sniper are you
gorilla like what's going on you're the
guys
that's all I [ __ ] do free proud
so you spawn and you're in a world free
for all so it's everybody against
everybody you know what I mean and uh
yeah I hit the board first place second
place third place out of four people all
the time how many people four ten I was
kidding I thought there's a hundred on
Call of Duty I think it's only 10 or 12.
oh that's weak as hell I thought you
were [ __ ] killing like 100 people no
no no fortnite's 100 people oh that's
what it was that's what it was so you
can go is it cities is it jungle like
whatever you pick [ __ ] well whatever it
is you know you ever play Call of Duty
before no it's just Wars on [ __ ]
randomly it comes up how do you get
which weapons do you like well you have
to build your weapons you have to get
good and then you as you're getting
better you're freaking pack your bag
your profile is accruing better weapons
it's getting better your [ __ ] your
your ranks going up tell them about when
you play me and Madden and then we
usually happen you know I'll play Madden
I'll play sometimes this guy I always
have to let my Ringo win but I pray him
sometimes do training sessions yeah if I
start beating him you say like do
sometimes you know what you won't play
anymore
I had to start FaceTiming him because he
was letting his son [ __ ] take over
some of the times some [ __ ] and then
he slipped up and I heard his son go you
want me to kick the next field goal
again and I was like oh you [ __ ]
cause he can't kick good no you know no
just the [ __ ] the new manic came out
and the field goal was all [ __ ] up
my son was like
yeah I'll be like [ __ ] here kick my
field goal here you remember you have no
problem scoring this [ __ ] but just
[ __ ] his son's good is good and
remember the first time I played him
remember he's like I don't play this
phone no more
I don't know what it is dude I'm only
good at Madden with Cam Newton other
than that I'm not good do you only play
with the Raiders yeah that's it okay
that's why he sucks and then okay so now
in fortnite it's you sitting there
talking [ __ ] to 400 little kids no
actually no so that one you can't talk
to nobody what no you can't avoid that's
good you can't come on I'm Call of Duty
I could sometimes you know I'll just
tell him shut the [ __ ] up because
they're talking too much [ __ ] but I
don't get too local with them because
you know I'm just like [ __ ] bro it's
like my kids probably right here so yeah
but most time I don't know it's funny
because I never get a kid to tell me
something anything back they're just
like oh [ __ ] you just shut up I don't
like putting the mic on I like Muni I
don't want to hear nobody it bugs me
because if I hear people talking [ __ ]
I'm like yo
I don't want this negativity ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] just pouring into my mind
no when [ __ ] are on I'm like
yeah those are the ones you just checked
you just tell them bro yeah you just
checking for the one time I got back on
it me and this guy I only did it once so
whoever you are that was that was me me
and this fool had a full-on like you're
a [ __ ] he's like well [ __ ] you [ __ ]
suck I don't know what it was I threw
like 40 interceptions in
I could not get the ball down the field
and I was like
and he's like just quit what are you
doing it was like 40 to 6 in the second
quarter I'm like how did I throw four
picks in a row running back like how was
his posse he was jumping every [ __ ]
pass I'm like
maybe I'm [ __ ] lobbing it and I I'm
not gonna quit I don't like quitting
games people quit after two touchdown
laws I'm like nah [ __ ] that I'm trying
to play the game I don't care about
losing I just want to play the game and
I was down like 60 to 7.
and then he started just going
[ __ ] with you bro I can't believe you
had to stop playing I'm like man I just
want to [ __ ] play just play the
[ __ ] game shut the [ __ ] up and then
he's like all right cool we're just
talking [ __ ] to each other for like 40
minutes and at the end I'm like
all right man you're not a [ __ ] that
was kind of fun all right are you lost
by 70 but it's okay and then I [ __ ]
try to play again it was the same dude I
was like I'm done I just oh my God I was
like no you matched me the same dude out
of the whole earth you imagine the same
guy right back to back I'm out and
that's like does that mean you know what
I mean the time is already late it was
like four in the morning yes that's why
I can't play games yeah I'll be up all
night get away from me but yeah I only
do the mic once and the whole time like
[ __ ] you you're a [ __ ]
if the mic would work on fortnite it
would be cool watch you can hear babies
[ __ ] going 100 people that's a lot of
[ __ ] people [ __ ] uh and you know
I'm pretty sure you can keep track only
in your range you hear that'd be kind of
cool yeah only people around you you
pick up the mic in the game that'd be
cool what you would hear in real life
yeah because a hundred voices sounds
like Bruce Almighty like yeah it's crazy
it's like going on Discord magic
playing [ __ ] um one hour a day that's
all that's not true no GTA no NBA no
other [ __ ] no random [ __ ] we wouldn't
know about
okay [ __ ] just get on from work did
you play San Andreas
off the [ __ ] mind and then did you
play what San Andreas
yeah yeah that's a good game I would
actually play that one too if I you know
but
I just hadn't kept up with it I mean I
kept up more like with these other games
more because of my son you know like
fortnite I would have never got into
fortnite my grandson if it wasn't for
him you know I was playing with Tim
every day now he don't even play
fortnite but now I'm more like [ __ ] I'll
play fortnite [ __ ] you know what I
mean because it's pretty fun you know I
like to [ __ ] I like I like to snipe a
lot you know what I mean so that's my
thing I don't know anything that's cause
I want to get into that [ __ ] I don't got
a sniper gun in fortnite I won't even
play it you know what I mean I don't
know [ __ ] that game
uh this guy can't play that way I
[ __ ] hate fortnite you got to teach
him I don't like I played it 10 times I
got two two first place out of ten
I cheated
I ran around while everybody was [ __ ]
shooting each other because I couldn't
build and I shot one guy behind a tree
and he almost killed me and somebody
else killed my ran almost died and then
I watched these dudes and I sat under a
bush and I watched did you shoot each
other to build a skyscraper and then I
just shot the bottoms of the skyscrapers
out
and then they [ __ ] died both of them
fell and died and I forgot first place
it was kind of awesome I'm gonna be
honest I just sat on it and started
shooting with my snipers they [ __ ]
hate it they were pissed I can hear him
talk oh no yeah no I couldn't hear him
talking
well I'm pretty sure
who was with me that they were pit
no no I was with somebody that they were
pissed like bro how are you gonna
[ __ ] do that exactly I was like [ __ ]
this game who was I think it might be my
brother I don't know who I was with but
I remember somebody was yeah my son will
tell me [ __ ] like that like you can't do
that all night I lose my brother he's
like you can't camp like that like [ __ ]
you see the first place
and then I played a couple more times
and lost in two seconds just ate apples
or some [ __ ] yeah cut logs and then and
then the next one I won everybody was
shooting at each other and I just
started shooting a guy in the back and
then he killed that guy and then by the
time he was almost dead I just won never
played it again [ __ ] that game
yeah I stopped cleaning for a minute and
then lately I started being called Duty
and then it [ __ ] went back to this
like I got the new Call of Duty I
haven't played it yet 1940s I couldn't
do it I was like [ __ ] that so I'm
waiting for the new car for new Call of
Duty to come up there's another now
there's another one remember right oh my
God they're bringing back Gold Line too
by the way I just saw who we just talked
about demise yes brought that up yeah I
saw a post that shit's coming back the
[ __ ] I never really [ __ ] people
going there yeah I [ __ ] with it I mean
[ __ ] one hour a day that [ __ ] helps
me out like right when I get home from
work
[ __ ] first thing I'll do is play
[ __ ] one hour at the most and then
you know get first place a few times
that's it all right listen to this fool
you know what my nightly routine I come
home I decompress I get a couple years
Call of Duty for sure first place
you know what sometimes it takes me a
week
like three days to get a win cause I'm
like send us your screen of your
Wednesday I'll pop it up you lying
you guys should be doing this [ __ ] on
Twitch he should be on Twitch just
shirtless [ __ ] tattoos going like
this
hey what's up what's up Meathead that's
how he answers did the FaceTime when I
call him like brothers call me after
we've talked about this before yeah
what's up so you lost okay yeah
oh [ __ ] this call me later how many
times he's put me in his pocket at work
like yo call me back call me [ __ ]
back bro I can hear him walking through
the Groves like oh hold on one second in
the pocket that must be in the pocket
she's having a conversation somebody
else like call me back
you [ __ ] creep
I have in my pocket wow the person's got
no idea [ __ ] yeah that I'm listening
the whole conversation you [ __ ] spy
all right here we go
so we talked about the Raiders
we're back we're past that we talked
about you cutting your damn hand off
oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
he's looking to see
dude it feels so good that you know I
mean [ __ ] it's almost it's almost
totally healed since the start of the
episode oh yeah Wolverine yeah
[Music]
that's why he poses like that
does the head nod that's what my dad was
trying to show me oh is that what makes
the Wolverine
is that what this is
oh it makes sense now what would you
would you like it leads you to the
answer just tells Professor X talking
about orbs
get it now no glasses can't read you
your Rogue
your storm he's an X-Men that's what I'm
trying to say how do you say X-Men in
Spanish
what do you mean how do you say this
with the words how you speak in Spanish
how do you say the letter x in Spanish
and then men in Spanish
um [ __ ] I don't know you're a liar are
you ready
I'm gonna flick this [ __ ] at you like
[ __ ] paper football if you don't tell
me X-Men in Spanish you know X-Men in
Spanish
the last like Chucky when he first get
the possession
you robot [ __ ] oh gee how do you
say X-Men in Spanish how are you failing
class right now you speak this [ __ ]
absolutely Hombres am I wrong that's
what I'm trying to say
[ __ ] know he said it
you can't just tell me I want to know
how to say X-Men in Spanish he's trying
to break it out of me
he's gonna deflect so hard until Marty
says it [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jedi Mind tricking me into being [ __ ]
Spanish
that was me
that my legs extend I'm tall sometimes
all right here we go so we did the fan
questions we asked you about the Raiders
ask you about your hand talked about
aliens today a lot of them we talked
about paranormal [ __ ] please tell me
about your [ __ ] ghost story as
that's what I was trying to talk to you
about your grandpa you just floated by
on your mustache [ __ ] went over the
question
um Yosemite Sam that's you
go like this
all right so do it for me
Don't Get Around the question look at
him Yosemite Sam please tell us about
ghost story oh like my grandfather's
house yes man that's what I said tell us
about Mexico and your grandpa that's
what I meant
[ __ ] this guy's so I said it earlier I
mean I mean
I don't know [ __ ] stop here we go oh my
God
look at the easy story you could say hey
man OG's family has some property in
Mexico
that we always go back to I mean
obviously I don't know if it's them but
obviously if we keep hearing [ __ ]
huge setup [ __ ] noises [ __ ] from like
like certain [ __ ] we here
like I just tell my mom I won't be like
oh well yeah that's right we used to
hear that that was your [ __ ] your my
dad used to do that all the time walk
around the pad smoking cigarettes and
we're here like [ __ ] scraping boots
and I'll be like who the [ __ ] is is
someone out there scraping [ __ ]
walking in their boobs like every
[ __ ] night from like 3 A.M to like
[ __ ] 4 am in the woods off in the
distance somewhere this is just [ __ ]
town he's in Mexico you set up [ __ ]
terrible just hearing [ __ ] just you
know what just hearing [ __ ] just him
walk around the whole house like back
back and have a wall around the whole
property yeah like a big wall around
their whole [ __ ] giant property okay
damn you said she looked crazy
you set you up so bad you told me the
story a couple days ago again you said
it so well you painted a picture in my
head and now you're okay so we got this
[ __ ] property so you know people like
[ __ ] from around our [ __ ] town
they always say like hey you know we
always see this [ __ ] um we always see
the the guy smoking cigarettes with the
hat and you know and
no no I was like what the [ __ ] so now
we're like wait a minute they always
mentioned this one man that supposedly
takes care of our house smoking a
cigarette well I mean there's nobody
there like that so yeah it's like our
grandfather you know what I mean that's
why I mean he's the only one who smokes
cigarettes because nobody even smokes
cigarettes I mean I don't smoke
cigarettes than anybody else will
seriously yeah you tell stories we don't
have any any straight homeless people
lurking around but look he's at the
toughest [ __ ] just
[ __ ] the people be telling me that
they see an old Thin Man a tall man with
a hat smoking cigarettes walking around
the property at night every [ __ ] day
he said everybody says that we see him
and that his grandpa used to walk around
he's the tall guy with the hat and boots
it's a ghost hmm you tell somebody
well he's there all the time you know
what I mean so I mean until this day
even if you're going down [ __ ] we still
[ __ ] if you're up at those hours you
can hear some [ __ ] and then I asked him
you never seen him and he goes no I've
only heard his boots scraping around and
I walk out and no one's there
but he's just watching now is this his
property [ __ ] that it's not worth it and
then to me it's like honestly I think
he's taking care of it of course he's
taking care of us too when we're there
because I mean uh [ __ ] I would hear this
[ __ ] for like almost a whole hour and
I'll be like [ __ ] out there [ __ ]
walking around and in my head the pitch
the our house we expand is bigger but
back then it was more just like a you
know it's like a triangle you know like
a square you know more like a square
type of house you know so yeah like a
[ __ ]
a walkway just went all around the house
all around the house so maybe that's
what he used to do all the time was just
walk around the house and smoke a
cigarettes yeah so that's what I was
hearing I go man I could hear him the
boots getting farther further further
and then come back again and then they
come back again so I always thought like
[ __ ] who's out there somebody out there
[ __ ] walking around and finally I
told my mom I go you know what who's out
there at night you know walking around
because you know I hear this and they're
like what they're like dude that my dad
used to do that which is my grandfather
Yeah why they used to always smoke
cigarettes oh [ __ ] all right that's what
it is and then Neighbors from around
started always talking about this man
smoking
yeah we're like what the [ __ ] same thing
like him you know what I mean like damn
it's a trip you know that's a good story
yeah yeah that last 40 seconds was a
story thank you yeah there we go there
we go man got captivated
I'll even be at night sometimes sleeping
in her house over there in Mexico and
all here are people talking outside
like like if there's a whole little
gathering outside chilling and you open
the door and there's nobody out there I
don't know what it's about Mexico I feel
like
it's a lot more like people know that
shit's real out there so I feel like
there's so much more [ __ ] down there
I keep like for my family tells me like
this there's more spirits and [ __ ] that
are more open and people talk about it
like well it's the spirits [ __ ]
stay away from over there yeah or that
part of the forest don't [ __ ] walk
over there because my grandma tells me
what parts of she's like oh hell no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] those people that lady is a
witch or weird [ __ ] you know what I mean
why isn't it why isn't this prevalent
here in America because even here even
here I hear [ __ ] and I see [ __ ] yeah for
sure for sure but not like
I don't know like I feel like my family
tells me about Mexico it's more like
open to like yeah of course it goes what
are you talking about stay away from
there oh you know over here it's like
you're crazy that's built into their
belief system in like Santeria and all
that that's what I'm saying I feel like
over there things are more like
yeah of course you're a crazy mythology
too in Mexico too like with like Joey
and all that [ __ ] like no I get it I get
it you know stories that were created
back then and [ __ ] you know what I mean
they just kept us on morning over and
over to generations and people think
like oh [ __ ] it is true yeah I mean
that's like any religion yeah exactly
I'm pretty sure everyone does it too
right I mean just like you know
they got like the white folks got
something you know like he pointed Marty
so black people got something white
folks got something they all gotta thank
you mythology it comes from their town
and where they believe in some type of
girl yeah for sure
but I just feel like it's more open I
don't know at least my with my grandma
they tell me about [ __ ] it's just
probably there's more stories about it
about Mexico but also my grandma's on
some wild [ __ ] with the dream [ __ ] she
has that book she knows about that [ __ ]
so that's why when I was a kid like damn
why is that yeah I remember talking
about my dream [ __ ] like oh so this is
real
all right so that's why I'm like yeah
sometimes my hair come on bro a new
building I just moved it and so I was
like oh man yeah I'm gonna do this [ __ ]
I don't have oh like here [ __ ] flip
back no I got combed and parted
it went back all licky nice could you
imagine right now like sorry don't come
back ghost that does my hair but I don't
gotta do [ __ ] that'd be hard could you
imagine you had a ghost haunt you that
was a hairdresser like sorry [ __ ] I'm
so scared I just called me cornrowing me
out and [ __ ]
head shoulders commercial
oh
like my manager had strings did
everything well I got sexually harassed
at my [ __ ] job when I was like 16.
but I didn't I felt so [ __ ] [ __ ] like
I was like oh get away from me I think I
talked about I did Mighty Taco
I think I talked about it this fool said
Mike Taco Mighty Taco never worked at
Taco Bell there's a place called Mighty
Taco yeah it's awesome
step brother you ever heard of Mighty
Taco is that some is that someone I
guess so do they have just meat and
cheese tacos because if they do that in
his white people it was dog food it was
[ __ ] horrible in in in flour
tortillas only
barely I don't even know Cows say
because then it is okay yeah never mind
I love flower turkey I don't go far yeah
I mean [ __ ] but hold on what I was
saying is I worked at Italian restaurant
this guy named Sam [ __ ] you this guy
named Sam he was the manager of strings
I hope he still [ __ ] manages it and
he's married so [ __ ] you this guy named
Sam he was at strings he was my manager
I was there for like
oh five days my fifth day I was a
dishwasher I was in the 11th grade
issues oh come to think about this guy
named Joe he was a cook Joey Diaz
basically he was Joe all right
[ __ ] he had this crazy ass
[ __ ] stories he got stabbed he got
stabbed a hell of times a bouncer he's
good now we got stabbed out of this
[ __ ] bar I just thought of this
[ __ ] anyway he was cool it's
like my fourth to fifth day and I'm
leaving and I'm like putting my stuff
away I'm like Sam you need to do
anything else he's like no I think I
think you're good man he's like a
foreign like a middle eastern dude but
like looks white probably Armenian you
know I mean like he's from the Middle
East or yeah my geography is trash help
me
even Israel or I don't know anyway he's
got a slight beard he looks at the dudes
that have the cuts haircuts and the
Mexican Barbers they go which number do
you want because of the views of the
like Aaron yeah
like Aaron one of those guys anyway I'm
standing there and he goes oh you have a
I'm asking do you need me to do anything
else I know you can go you have
something in your hair and go oh okay
I was getting it and he goes no other
side I was like uh all right I got it
and he goes hold on and I was like okay
it's all good and then he went like this
Pretend This is my head here's my
forehead he went
and grabbed it off my [ __ ] like he
was doing a dance
he went like this and I felt him go
and he touched my head and then grabbed
it out he could have just went
and he looked at me so I got it and I
went
I am 16 years old I'm also straight but
16. get the [ __ ] away from me and I
ended up quitting that place not because
of that because he [ __ ] tried to
stiff me on something about Sam and I'm
not gonna say anything else but I hate
them but I do have a friend
that worked you know what I gotta leave
it alone it'll be two I mean that'll be
too much I'll leave that other story out
but he harassed me he could have just
picked it out of my hair and he groped
my whole [ __ ] scalp and as I as he
did I went oh I could feel like oh like
you know what I mean like get the I feel
violent even if a girl did that to me I
was like
scalp grope that's went like that and
like spread his face
dude did you just like
passive
you're married the owner's your
father-in-law
I am 16 years old sir I think I've told
him somewhere so somewhere I talked
about it I swear I've talked about it
are you okay though
I'm okay I uh he shipped me on eight
hours of work so I stole hella pieces of
lasagna and and moose heads six packs I
added it up how much we would sell it
for and I made it an exactly 88 so I'm
not a thief so I was like boom I think
they're up like 84. I couldn't get
anything else that was four dollars to
make it even so I was like
it back so hell lasagna what a fat piece
of [ __ ] there's no Frozen pieces of
lasagna I'm like those are 12 bucks oh
I'm gonna get five of those
[ __ ] and I still I put them in
the trash
bags and I took the trash out when my
uncle John would pick me up I'd grab
them and I'd go and like yo I got some
[ __ ] Mooseheads let's get [ __ ] up
and lasagna it was cool [ __ ] that job
anyway
after that you have like a month month
and a half at least no [ __ ] time so
you liked it homie [ __ ] you but I
remember thinking like yo that was wild
but I quit with my Uncle John when he
had all like when he had eight ball
Pizza weed and Miller highlights I'm
like I'm not going to work and I quit
over the phone that's the job
that's the job I'm talking about again
with my Uncle John
yeah there's some wild [ __ ] man uh [ __ ]
that
um so now I see why you don't want your
girl to work bro they might grip her
hair and pick some food out of her hair
sorry and she lives on Earth
sometimes she happens you know wait a
minute it's a good call back it was good
that was good I mean like that you fool
I didn't mean like that fool yo speaking
of why is Pinocchio on there oh because
it's on Disney anyway me and Rosie try
to watch the I think it's French the
French version of Pinocchio what the
[ __ ] bro I watch it on some platform
during quarantine
it was [ __ ] weird creepy and I
thought he was gonna [ __ ] the doll
that's how I felt me and Rosie both
looked at each other like is she gonna
[ __ ] this I know you but he was a real
boy he was a piece of wood that turned
into a real boy she had like wood skin
but the way the dad was with it was like
I'm a [ __ ] bounce we got about 40
minutes like yo I I don't like
abandoning movies because I already put
my time into it but I think I'm off of
the French [ __ ] doll [ __ ] movie
you'll watch the Pinocchio movie I feel
like it's [ __ ] with Disney right I don't
know I don't think it was a Disney I
don't think it was from Disney I don't
think it was man I think it was a
bootleg ass version that made it to the
internet because I watched on one of the
apps I was like a French Pinocchio real
boy Pinocchio I don't even know Disney
had a version I want to just watch that
one
oh it was [ __ ] weird it was creepy
and then the kid fell asleep by the fire
and burned his legs off yeah well we
already went over how creepy like Peter
Pan was these a lot of these movies are
based and creepiness to begin with you
put some [ __ ] hey Peter Pan might be
a creep but hey hook version Rob
Williams uh I'm not gonna say any
creepiness about it he was just a
business he's a businessman yeah just
creeping Windows kidnapping them
kidnapping [ __ ] true story yeah
true story Hook was dope you have no
ashes on your chest oh [ __ ] okay okay
we're at this part you know what for you
to pee again oh no
okay guys
key right there
lift up your pant like LL Cool J
you have to turn your take your glasses
off that's why you couldn't see look at
him why is it dark in here there you go
there you go you walked into a platform
bendy with glasses to the cat thing hey
so why is it dark in here did you see it
so I'm not gonna dumb he does do [ __ ]
like this I'm not making it up bro
wasn't dark in here and it was real
people like that
he's got your sunglasses on and it's 10
o'clock at night in a dark room in a
soundproof light proof room
how you feeling
dehydrated yeah a lot of pee in you
two shots it's the first beer would you
drink that whole bottle that's one beer
no it was three there's been one [ __ ]
beer there no it was three beers there's
we I we took out three beers for all
three of us
and I [ __ ] there's only one cup of
wine
my [ __ ] he's only taking two shots
don't try to just make it up for it
you're scaring your peeing your pants is
okay
you peanuts your ass
hey I'm just going with the ammunition
you [ __ ] giving me sir
I'm just peeing out my [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] all right
that's how dogs drink
it's a dog straight now
oh [ __ ] I sip it I don't want to start
peeing everywhere
[Laughter]
yo okay hold on
we were talking about ghosts
we're talking about aliens
oh some wild [ __ ] I want to say some I
think I told you I don't think I told
you yo
Rosie had a surgery we talked about it
Rosie under surgery
and
the morning of you obviously I'll
stressed the [ __ ] out the morning of I
told you I think I don't know if I told
you I was like yo
I was like praying and she was like yo
make sure everybody's okay please I'm a
[ __ ] she's a good ass person you know
I mean like she's good please make sure
she's all right and then I was like yo
John Michael John I'm like where the
[ __ ] you're at stop what you're doing
and go help Rosie and make sure she's
good you know man I don't think I told
you I was like whatever you're doing
[ __ ] help me and I started well left
the hospital and I started doing [ __ ]
and then I was thinking about my uncle
John all [ __ ] day I don't know why
randomly we're just I was just like
little things I saw him like huh
yeah all right cool he would like that
[ __ ] I was just thinking [ __ ] and then
Rosie got out of the [ __ ] surgery
and I'm talking to her and she's like
coming out of like like being [ __ ] up
and I was like yo I gotta know
I don't know anybody who's been in
surgery like this what the [ __ ] did you
dream about like that's a question I
wanted to ask like yo what did you dream
about in the [ __ ] crazy Church like
I was with John the whole time he said
that I had to come help you hang out
with you and he kept making fun of me
because my mouth was all [ __ ] swollen
and he said I looked stupid and he said
I looked ridiculous he's like my whole
mouthful you look like a chipmunk and
he's like we were just hanging out and
he's like you're at the hospital I'm
here to help you uh while you're here
and then make sure you're good and then
she's like I was like shut the [ __ ] up
and she's like yeah that was it
like the whole time he's like yeah
you're just sitting we were just talking
damn isn't that [ __ ] crazy
what did you feel when she's [ __ ]
cried instantly I couldn't hold that
[ __ ] and I was like she's all [ __ ] up
I'm looking at him like oh [ __ ] I'm like
you [ __ ] thank you like no
matter what I know you're okay because
you were able to come help me you know I
mean like it just like made me feel like
thank god dude I you know what I mean
like
I knew you were doing something okay I
know you were all right somewhere
wherever the [ __ ] you're at doing some
stupid [ __ ] I know you know I mean like
made me feel better like
I asked and wrote that's the first thing
she tells me this is not fake good [ __ ]
feel better oh yeah pretty [ __ ] cool
man yeah yeah it was pretty [ __ ] cool
I was like
and that day before I just texted Madden
question mark I just do it randomly
makes me feel better because he would
text me all the time Madden like oh you
want to get high today let's get high as
[ __ ] today and play mad and that's where
he used to text me like in the morning
and when I moved he would text me like
[ __ ] I'm gone he's like I know [ __ ]
like I know this suck I don't hold them
like almost every day uh anyway yeah in
this one's crazy spiritual ass [ __ ] that
is crazy pretty wild and the fact he's
like you look ridiculous your face is
all swollen it's like yo you're in
surgery why the [ __ ] would you be saying
that that is awesome I know a lot of
people like yeah you guys are high you
guys smoke a lot of weed like also [ __ ]
you then
ghost was made for a reason yeah
synchronistic [ __ ] happens for sure oh
yeah it's crazy
yeah but also when people reincarnation
it takes at least a couple years
um this motherfucker's still not back
they're gonna say like he's still doing
something so obviously reincarnation
takes a while
if that's if that's a real thing
that's what I'm thinking I had a glitchy
moment that probably only really maybe
once or twice in life where it was like
slow motion it was at
the awards ceremony for my dad's
induction into the Buffalo Music Hall of
Fame I was accepting his award
and it was like a slow motion moment
probably like 80 percent of the way
through the night I think after I got on
stage and [ __ ] where I just kind of
looked over and one of the dudes against
the wall I caught a glitch
of my dad in the dude oh [ __ ] that just
was like a freeze frame that I'll never
forget it was one frame
and then I it was like back to reality
and it was just like a moment that'll
always like stick with me like just I
don't know there's only been like two or
three moments where it's like a GTA slow
down one on one frame slow motion old
[ __ ]
and then back to real life
I don't know that's not like a ghost
thing to me it's just I don't think it's
a dream but it was real it happened to
me in the grocery store those are my
grandma I knew my grandma was dead I ran
to like
oh yeah oh where am I at [ __ ]
the store and wake I ran up to almost
tapped her on the shoulder I could like
walk 30 feet to this lady and was like
Grandma what the [ __ ] and I was like
Thomas you high [ __ ] but I swear
to God it was her like I'm low over
looking at her it was weird moment
yeah
once my daughter I don't know if I took
this if I see the story before if I ever
told you I think I lost my little uh my
girl my youngest daughter I think she
was like um
but she's like me about three three
years old four maybe three or four
and we're at the beach bro and [ __ ]
she I don't know she got lost bro we're
like what the [ __ ] going crazy looking
for a bra [ __ ] local bro I mean [ __ ]
so this day has to remember all the
[ __ ] the feeling it was just horrible
feeling real and I went up to literally
some people like hey I lost my daughter
bro you would think people would get up
and start helping you look bro [ __ ] now
bro they're like they had to look like
well stupid it's your phone damn it's
like [ __ ] bro it just it was a [ __ ]
horrible feeling bro so I where it was
smack this guy we're looking we're
[ __ ] already going crazy you know
[ __ ] Michael was already crying
[ __ ] oh local and [ __ ]
dude this [ __ ] lady out of nowhere in
a white [ __ ] like this white
certain type of like cloth dress gray
hair blue eyes bro brings me my daughter
walks up to this
like with the most gentle voice and
everything bro it's so [ __ ] weird
it wasn't well I want to say it was
weird but it was like what the [ __ ] like
at the moment we're like oh thank you
you know [ __ ] you know I shook around
and thank you you know and [ __ ] but
after that like I kind of like who was
that lady really
you know before she looked it was just
it was she had long hair like past her
[ __ ] waist gray hair blue eyes
white with this white like type of like
a certain type of clothing I don't know
explain it but it's a dress but it was
like a different type of material it was
just in nothing from here and it was
like what the [ __ ] and she's the one
around my daughter weird and I was just
like [ __ ] I have to know I think about
me I don't know that was an angel or you
know I mean that's that's why I think it
was you know
but it was [ __ ] it's horrifying how
they still think about like damn like
out of everybody who just brings your
daughter to you and tells you oh here
you go right yeah and knows it's your
daughter
exactly you're in the worst pain of all
time right I mean I don't know it was
crazy she was already a couple of tears
down and then [ __ ] it was you know it
was crazy
like how does they find us knew we were
the ones that last one lost the kid or
something
trippy [ __ ] but yeah so I believe that
that was that was some type of angel
that you know better back to me
cool like you know
that's what like you know I didn't think
about at the moment because at the
moment you just [ __ ] you know oh cool
thank you I mean after that I'm gone and
you know two three days later you start
thinking about who was this lady was
that your only kid at the time no that
was my actually that was my fourth kid
oh okay so you lost one I gotcha it's
like trying to hold puppies into a
[ __ ] containment One's Gonna Get out
the other ones we're like okay cool and
this one just went [ __ ] wondering off
wondering enough wondering now who
Natalie oh it's most yeah so you know I
thought I I thought for a minute ago
okay she's not in the water because I
knew she was always scared of the water
she was no way she'll be in the water
so I knew that
so I go [ __ ] someone had to take it so I
was already trying to like [ __ ] run
towards the parking lot
oh that's when some lady walked up with
her
damn dude I know what you mean one time
I lost like a half ounce man I know the
feeling dude yeah
it's some old white no
an old white man I can't even long gray
hair because you know I can't even see
an old lady because she did not look
like I can't describe her as old so she
was she just looked [ __ ] like she
dyes her hair great
nah you know what it was just
I don't know how to explain it
it was an issue that a certain age that
just she just looked
right and good like he was just the [ __ ]
she was biblical her aging looked like
[ __ ] she looked biblical you know she
didn't know she didn't look all [ __ ]
like you know wrinkled yeah yeah no she
looked young but she just looked good
like why and she looked like like she
could have looked old because her gray
hair but it didn't match like you know
like [ __ ] gray hair her complexion was
just so [ __ ] you know in place and
blue blue eyes like these eyes that just
got your attention
[Music]
um
sometimes I wish I could understand the
[ __ ] meanings of this here you say
she was old
no I kind of say she was old so she was
young because of the gray hair that's
like there okay
she [ __ ] hair complexion everything
would just look not even when she flew
away why didn't you think that she asked
him she walked into the ocean above it
yeah yeah I swear I promise I don't know
I'm gonna figure out how to do that
all my arms are enough I'm gonna lift
it's something that sticks with you I
feel like that afterwards you're kind of
like that was a moment like there was
two or three of those things it was like
my my my state of like my state of mind
my my where I was at the moment I was so
[ __ ] free and so [ __ ] like
like you know I was losing them bro so
it's like something came to my assistant
one of the worst moments in life one of
the worst moments that can happen in
life yeah dropping a joint in the rain
oh [ __ ]
I know a lot of you just imagine went oh
so I should join down the toilet no
that's that's gone it's watching and
looking at it knowing you can't do
nothing about it that's as bad as losing
a child at the beach yeah
I'm not the only one here that's not a
dad so I'm just talking [ __ ] I don't
understand yeah
it's his baby yeah I mean maybe the same
[ __ ] yeah same [ __ ] see all right he
said it he said it I mean again you
compared you know you yeah you agree
with me
it's all right OG's gonna go to New York
and he's gonna wear big parachute pants
everybody's gonna think his dog face
he's gonna skate there like dog face
did everybody think you're dark faced
still before we get out here no food
nobody DMS you no more
please only my son thinks I'm dogs is
dog food is still out is he a slow thing
or I don't know I just I think he looks
like dog faces
that's very season one that's very
season one that is very season one but
I'd ask do people still think you talk
please
people think I'm uh this fat Mexican kid
that sings high-pitched uh old oldies
you see him on the internet he sings
bomb he looks like me you could have a
Channel singing oldies I could see that
he looks like you want to stick hair
back yeah he sings oh my position
he said the old Mexican oldies that kid
that kid he doesn't I mean I'm not gonna
lie he does like like my darker slightly
like
figure cheat cousin yeah definitely I
could see how it could be a son it could
be his kid yeah like his Uncle
like my brother and it would be his
uncle because I'm his dad okay
you like that
science science get the [ __ ] out of here
okay okay okay
um before we get out of here where don't
you post on Instagram
yeah where don't you post that what's
the name of the guy that you don't use
what don't I post you know the account
that you don't use what is the account
so we can just throw it out there for no
[ __ ] reason again because you don't
use it
how do you spell it underscores o g
double e k-u-s-h 7-6 no underscores
it'll be right here go ahead and follow
it guys if you want to watch nothing
I mean
I mean I do got [ __ ] I could pulls but
uh it's like episode three you better
get comments and you know I can't answer
back because I'm [ __ ] so busy and
[ __ ] with your feet up smoke a joint at
work yeah I know you can't answer
comments yeah it's like Grow rooms
Whittier Boulevard Grow rooms Whittier
Boulevard right yeah that's pretty much
the story Bossa Nova
and Miss angle
all right all right I'll tell you what
nothing tell me what you guys know I'm
doing I want you to post motivational
quotes and speeches every morning I want
you to get up and push from the sauna
like Major Payne hanging upside down
cleaning your guns or like 50 Cent In
the Club
hey I can do that
don't come into that because we all know
you're doing that
um [ __ ] I don't know what does everybody
want to see I mean so to me I don't know
what they want to see so you don't post
anything I don't know I mean [ __ ] if you
guys tell me what you guys want to see
they want you being a ventriloquist for
the gremlin I'll [ __ ] I'll post it
I'll tell you that no that's not true I
can tell you what they want to see
you doing anything
you roll a joint you're smoking a joint
you showing the [ __ ] you know you can
post stuff on your account you don't
have to just post on the story when it's
gone for 24 hours look at him smiling
he's like I know we need a new me and OG
oh that's coming out soon sorry a new a
new episode of Me no G we're doing
another episode
I believe next month we gotta do
something sooner that's too long all
right I know this feels real scared you
don't like to post the internet I don't
know what else to tell them I don't even
bug you about it anymore I gave up you
don't post it's not that I don't post no
but it is my last account got taken down
you all have nothing but weed on this
account you think it's a difference
uh well
don't post the same picture with you and
Cheech and say you're uh uh I posted
stupid no because you're gonna count
that as a new pose that's what he was
gonna post tonight I bet you
we're big joint the big cross joy we did
forever ago oh I'll pull some [ __ ] [ __ ]
it from this point on you said that last
time a lot of [ __ ] I just got that do I
got a lot of Shaker pulled I just don't
know why I just don't do it but I'll
[ __ ] do it then right it's out of
fear [ __ ] it you got it you got it
credit card you got it hey Marty sir how
you feeling
I'm feeling [ __ ] cloudy I'm feeling
[ __ ] Cloud you you're blue
it blew it up today I had that exact
same shirt with just the print yesterday
for my friend's daughter's birthday the
same blue shirt no [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
hard yeah it's pretty hard it's just
authentic man I could feel it hey man
thank you for being here thank you for
talking about you know how to keep your
girlfriend in here please
[ __ ] idiot
oh my God yo man uh I could see how
YouTube gets mad at us sometimes I could
see it but we're just kidding and if you
think that's offensive then [ __ ] you're
boring that's cool none of these are on
huh but the front yeah we got one okay
we got one going all right so OG that's
your account that's your alien story
that's your spirit story that's your
horrible telling story about your
grandpa you told me immaculately a
couple days ago so when we were kids uh
everyone thinks that my grandpa is a
ghost this is so good the other day and
now he's over here
speak no but I was in there I was pacing
that I was in there I was deciphering it
I had it a little bit before and you
know I would have thought at least okay
cool you know at least at least [ __ ]
think about it while we're you know
getting started he just said he would
have made a storyboard he would have hit
him high as [ __ ] dude give me a [ __ ]
bong ramp actually before you're out
here can I get that
so I can show my son how it's done
that she doesn't want to do that he's
scared of all the boys at school he
always comes home like Dad Dad they
started messing with me again they
didn't like my Ken Stabler Jersey they
said the Raiders were gonna go 7 and 15.
and he's like they'd even have that many
games dad I was like don't worry son
I said [ __ ] it got it to the back of my
head then I sewed it shut and put a
couple screws in my neck that's him that
reminded me of that song
that was you headphones
you need headphones it was hard I need
some more Marshall Mathers on this
[ __ ] board I'm slipping
damn
people don't even know it's possible
that's how you were born
yeah okay
all right you know what man we needed
you here you haven't been here all
season too
oh no you have been here season dude you
were six months end of season one you
haven't been here in half a year the
next time you're on this show
two the next time you're on the show
we'll be at our new studio
you have to check in park
I go to the security
you're gonna be all awkward as you walk
through all the people working you're
like hey if one of those gonna be other
people here I thought it was just going
into my own world I can handle my gun
there you go yeah exactly here's my gun
it's legal yeah no we're gonna have you
your own bathroom set up close to the
set
yeah the access you'd be okay
um oh that's pretty cool all right you
ready you ready to get out of here thank
you for being here thank you appreciate
you weren't shaking this time you were
all good
you did good you did good today got the
confidence of Rocco you did get the the
confidence of a young 18 year old child
he did great because I loved it no Rock
was just that kid that's why yeah
[Music]
um
today was fine we're just chilling man
it's a chill episode we missed the whole
fight I'm sorry
you know who won [ __ ] come on I
don't know me this is [ __ ] good we
won the War on Drugs
let's see who won there's a Canelo fight
I thought GGG should take it but let's
see I'm pretty sure he's on the ticket
but
sure who GGG
Canelo leaves no doubt decides to
Victory is what I see wow oh there it is
he won defeats Triple G oh [ __ ] okay
well okay that's good
all right I think it's all just a
[ __ ] enough oh [ __ ] this is like
the third fourth fight or whatever
she has to be you know [ __ ] probably
Rick so I could [ __ ] be another fight
and you know that's cool three times
[ __ ] it four times he won already beat
him four times already white Mexican
dude right I don't know that's what my
grandma looks like that's why when
people like your grandma's message like
yo
she is from Acapulco
white blonde woman yeah
yeah [ __ ] you should know our
families are related somehow damn it's
not like DMX right there
I was just [ __ ] trying not to come
you should know
I was just confident
this is gay you're the Joe Pesci of our
show
slash Joey Diaz of our show
you're an idiot all right let's get out
of here thank you for being here thank
you for never post on your Instagram we
appreciate you man it was super sick to
watch you post nothing for 12 months
um didn't even post it here on the
podcast crazy [ __ ] nuts huh didn't
even post on his page about the podcast
he's on
[ __ ] only by the time this comes out
yeah by the time this one comes out
he'll be finished watching the last one
he watches four minutes a day that's
what he does he'll be posting about the
first one yep from season one
all right uh we'll see you later man you
[ __ ] fitment as fool thank you for
being here thank you for being here guys
this has been the dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments [ __ ] high
socks and everything in between thank
you guys so much for being here have a
dope ass day
are you all right don't worry don't
worry that was a good one it was fun now
go eat pizza and sit with the other kids
foreign
[Music]